You're saying that Steven has achieved the goal that he set out
to achieve, which was to have you and Queen Man and other quote-unquote
anti-fans
cover him less. So, you basically just said that the docs war
worked.
Yeah, like I don't get anything out of covering him. I don't
get more viewers out of covering him. Why would I cover him?
By the way, it didn't work on me or like like when he was starting
to doc me, I was like, oh that. Now he's starting to doc random
unrelated people. Starting to doc Wicked Supreme. He's doc eSports
Batman. Right? Like that now I'm like, oh well now you're just
going after people adjacent to me. Now that you are explicitly
doing the Kiwi Farms tactics to me, I'm like, oh well actually
whatever I can do to not get the people around me harassed, that's
actually what I'll do. I'm literally saying, hey you you won.
You're you're blab now. You won. You're blab now. Yeah, you're
you're blab now. So, you you won. What can I do to not get the
people around me harassed and doc?
What what is what is Substance say? We'll see if Substance is
accurate. Connor counter Connor says he's been way more nuanced
than the sweepers he's been accused of being among. He also says
that Jstock and Queen Man are walking back from their positions
with respect to the Destiny case, evidenced by them not covering
the latest unsealed transcript.
I I think both Queen Man and I on the Pixie case. So, I had one
conversation with Connor where we went over the rules for I think
uh what is it?
Uh cyber harassment I think in Florida and I thought you could
construct an intent in a certain way that made like made Pixie's
cyber harassment thing possible. But other than that, I think
I've basically said the whole time that with regards to Destiny's
civil case with Pixie, it's going to come down to what they see
in
>> In my opinion. I don't think I've ever I I think maybe
other than the first
two weeks to three weeks, I don't think I'd ever had the opinion
that Pixie was like in an advantage advantageous position that
she was going to win. I said it would come down to discovery.
But oh and then he wants to attribute Infinite Regress Machine
to me. Well, we'll we'll discuss that when he comes >> So,
when it comes to the Destiny sweepers, of which I've been accused
and yet I don't think that anybody's actually engaged with what
I've said,
the the sweepers have said, oh Destiny didn't do nothing.
You know, if she was 18, who would have
That this is no big deal. He should be able to do whatever he
wants to do.
Uh I don't think this is true. We I don't think he's openly said
he would he would lie for
gain for years. I I don't think that's
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah. That's what the sweepers
said. Okay? Now, what the attacker said is that he's a criminal.
He should be civilly liable. He should be criminal li- criminally
liable. He should be put on a list. He should do Okay.
A conservative liberalism says, if she was 18, who would have
cared? Well, you know, she was 17 and four months. So, let's
just say that people are people are sweeping a little bit too
hard right there, right? Right? I think they're sweeping too
But the sorry, let me let let me think about how to
articulate the richness. Jstock because the the perception, the
Okay, okay, hold on. This is this is up. Already what he's saying
is a little up, but I'm looking at what Weed says here. During
the Briana arc with Queen Man, he pushed he was pushed to admit
that he wouldn't publicly admit to true things that were negative
about her. He does the same now with Destiny. Shrug.
Um okay.
Maybe. Connor's got like the least the least effective way of
doing those
I thought I thought Dan was the least effective. Dan's like,
I'll lie for any reason, no matter what. And then he just says
that while he's like drunk or high on sleep meds and then he
he throws it out there. But Connor's like, no I I I'm the truth
is really important to me and all of these things and then he's
like, but I will also conceal it sometimes for gain, but also
truth is really I think it's like worse that somehow than Dan's
Remember how Connor used to say he never followed the drama and
just got tidbits from Destiny. Now he followed all of it and
is making strong claims based on him watching the videos. Well,
hold on. That's not what he's really saying and I'll I'll actually
probably have to write that down and make sure that I'm not getting
that wrong because it sounds like he's saying the external exterior
perception from watching Rile and it's like, no cuz I know watching
when you say watching Rile, you mean watching clips of my stream.
What he probably means is exterior perception of like watching
Rile's thumbnails and titles, which to be honest, I've complained
about publicly multiple times. I've complained to Rile directly.
I've complained about publicly multiple times. He's just making
his money. So, listen. Unfortunately, there are literally titles
and thumbnails that are like, Destiny's court case is over. And
I'm like, dude that's literally not my opinion. That's not what
I say in the
What am I supposed to do? Again, I don't know what I'm supposed
to do. That's literally that's what the thumbnail says. That's
what the title says in some
It's like, yeah that's not my opinion, but whatever. It's like
clickbait. I
But I I can't be held responsible for clickbait on a channel
I don't own or make any money from. Right? DMCA Rile? I don't
even know how to DMCA content on YouTube, but I don't have a
YouTube account. I don't know how I would DMCA Rile. I literally
don't.
And if I was going to DMCA some DMCA somebody, probably be Food
Shops for literally being incapable of as bad as like Rile might
be for making thumbnails, Food Shops is worse. She like watches
the content and then can't even comment or follow what any of
the arguments are. Okay?
So, if I was going to DMCA somebody, I'd probably start with
Ri- or sorry, with Food Shops and then Rile. Probably. Um okay.
Anyway,
>> I got to back this up just so we can get this whole
thing >> But the sorry, let me let let me think about how
to
articulate the richness. Jstock because the the perception, the
exterior perception from watching Rile Kitten House
was that So, I'm going to obviously challenge him on that. And
he says watching. That's wrong.
If he wanted to say the exterior perception from looking only
at Rile's thumbnails and titles is that Destiny's
I probably go, okay I'm not going to fight on that, but I have
limited control over that, okay? >> Uh Destiny was going
down. The civil suit was going to destroy him. The criminal suit
was going to destroy him. Everybody else is sweeping. Jstock's
the only truth teller. He's going to you know, he's going to
ride this thing you know, until the bitter end and and he's going
to hold Destiny accountable this that the other. Sherry is also
doing stuff in the background and everybody's going to be surprised
by what's happening there. And then what's happened since
She's not in the background.
Like I'm I'm trying I'm not going to talk about any Sherry stuff
here, but like publicly, let's just the public stuff is she filed
police report. That's public. It's not in the background. It's
literally just public. A police report has been filed publicly.
since then is the Sherry stuff never materialized past what I
said was probably going to happen. And then this should be regardless
of whether or not you're right or wrong. Regardless of whether
or not you're right or wrong, this would be great content, right?
Like Jstock covering
you know, released unredacted court transcripts
and then talking about it would be probably 700 to 1,000 live
viewers. This is wrong. And Connor Connor would have to go and
look at the last couple times I've covered his court case stuff
to know this. I literally got more viewers covering the court
case stuff than I've gotten covering Destiny drama the last four
or five times. Sorry, not court case stuff. Covering um the ice
shooting stuff. Like yesterday I think we hit 500 viewers a couple
times. Yesterday was a really good stream. Unfortunately,
the audience on Kick for for like me, they want to watch me cover
the news. They want like breaking news updates. They want like
analysis of that stuff. I What am I supposed to do? It's literally
better for all of us. That's what that's kind of like what I'm
going to ask explicitly is hey Connor,
are you and Destiny like explicitly asking me to cover his court
case right now? Cuz trust me, yesterday was like one of the best
days for content I've had in a long and it was nothing to do
with Destiny. And so when I say like I'm going to ban people
who bring it up, it's cuz I knew that there was good stuff there,
that I had opinions on it, that I wanted to cover it, right?
And I don't want to sit here dealing with like Destiny going,
oh why won't you cover the court case stuff? Yeah, I don't want
to deal with that. I don't even want to see in the chat. It's
like I'll just time you out if you're going to do it today.
Yeah, that's makes total sense, right? Yeah. Um yeah, I Rile
kept linking me some some Deep Rama tweet, which I didn't actually
watch
or or look at yet. You can link it now. And I'm like, dude I
I'm literally not clicking that. I'm I'm not. I'm I'm on the
politics stuff, okay?
Yeah, I also said I was going to cover it. And I am going to
cover it at some point. I would like to read it first
to be honest with you cuz I I think what I'd like to do is I'd
like to be able to go back and and point to things where I think
there are contradictions, but I haven't even read it myself yet.
I've not had the time to read it myself at
Dude, I'm I can't even explain how funny that that girl like
passing out was. Holy [__]
That was some funny stuff, man. Uh hold on. What's this Deep
Rama tweet?
I will say
>> Deep Rama had another tweet that I saw that I have to
echo,
which is just like
oh, here we go.
I would like to apologize to at the omniliberal. I fell for the
anti-fan narrative that he had been sending nudes of all of his
friends to an underage girl, when in fact he had been sending
them to the man
the underage girl. Total exoneration.
It's like, yeah, dude.
I do like that. I will just say
does Destiny D. Bravo said this and I was like, yeah. Does Destiny
know what he's being sued for anymore? Does Destiny know what
the original stuff was about? Does he even remember?
Or did he like create this entire sideshow by posting that PII
so Kiwi Farms could find Rose? Did he create like an entire sideshow
where now that's what he's litigating, and he's spending all
of his time litigating instead of the actual case itself? It's
like not even the case, and then beyond that it's not even the
actual reason he was canceled, which is like multiple women coming
out and saying this guy sent my nudes without consent. When he
had himself during the Bob 7 arc said, "Showing people's nudes
to someone else without their consent should be career
That's like the drama, right? That's That's where the the quote-unquote
drama kicked off. Where it's like, "Oh, this guy's like a really
bad person."
But he somehow he narrowed it under the Pixie case, and then
he narrowed it in under Rose again. And it's like, I don't I
literally don't even know if he's aware of like what the original
stuff with the original criticisms were. Oh, there's Lauren Southern
Laguna stuff, too. Very weird. Okay. Anyway. So, we might Maybe
we'll read it today. I don't know. I don't know for sure. What's
going on?
Uh pretty good. How are you? Uh decent.
Oh, it's all right. I got uh I got some I got some notes that
I wouldn't mind addressing with you. Yeah, sure. We'll We'll
finish the clip and then we'll go to the notes. be a ton of super
chat
It would probably be a lot of critics in chat, let's be real.
A lot of people would be criticizing him in chat, but it would
also probably be a lot of supporters. And the supporters would
probably, you know, enjoy him continuing to criticize Steven
in spite of what happened in in the court case. And so as a result,
it would have been like the perfect opportunity to make a ton
of
And then what happened when somebody
Jaystock, you know, "Hey, are you going to cover the Destiny
stuff?" He's like, "Nah, later."
Later, when I'm bored.
You know, I I I spent I spent three or four months covering this
as aggressively as possible, but now that it's not really going
my way, the way that I initially articulated it, you know, it's
it's boring. It's not interesting. I'm not going to That'll be
very interesting to go over. >> that as aggressively.
I was like, "Okay, well, that that feels like cope. That feels
like
Oh, um
I would just love to know basically if you have like an idea
of where especially clips would be super helpful or like any
quotes would be super helpful in terms of where the case is different
from what I said previously. >> the infinite rate machine,
right?
Sure. What do you think I said about the infinite rate machine?
I I took a very specific note, so I I want you to tell me if
I get it wrong. So,
it was Nicholas DeOrio. I I think you you were stating that he
miscovered the story, and if I understand the concept of the
infinite machine it's that Steven has a conveyor belt of Sorry.
Sorry, I'm I actually took a specific note. That Steven has a
conveyor belt of mentally ill women that he can have casual relations
with and then discard at his pleasure. And if they try to retaliate,
he can use his audience to harass and destroy them. If the women
knew what they were signing up for, they wouldn't participate
in this dynamic.
So, what I think you saw there, so first of all when I've talked
about the infinite machine on stream
it has been to give attribution, which is to President Sunday,
it's his
And it doesn't literally have to do with And even in the So,
I What I think you saw is probably a clip from a WillyMac video,
probably not even a clip from like my stream.
You probably saw a clip from a WillyMac video where he said that
I was doing that, but I clearly wasn't doing that, and multiple
other creators have called him out for just lying there.
Like I was literally saying >> But do you agree with my
characterization or definition? So, so for instance, if you're
saying it's an absolute president Sunday definition >> The
The infinite rate machine actually has a lot more to do with
the orbit than it does with like his audience necessarily. Um
how Well, how how do you disagree with the definition that I
read you, I suppose, is my question.
Uh I don't I think some part of it might that the women could
be mentally ill. It's basically using that mental illness cover
to like disregard what they're saying. It's It's coming up with
ways to discredit people who will eventually dislike this person.
And then having a bunch of people who reinforce that idea.
I think but again, this is like Sunday's metaphor, right? That
I didn't come up with. I do think the general narrative that
Destiny has like borderline abusive relationships with people.
Um some not even borderline, some actually just straight-up abusive
relationships with people. And then he uses whatever he can to
discredit them and their allegations. Uh no, I totally agree
with that. Okay. I mean, I still have notes, so if we want to
It's up to you if we want to get into the notes. If you want
to get to the clip first, we can finish the clip.
Well, I No, I don't mind talking about this. What do you disagree
with there? Um I don't disagree that uh
Steven has definitely relationships that I don't approve of and
and I don't think are criticisms known to him, and I've made
those criticisms known to other people. Um and I think I've said
them publicly as well. The um and I and I do think that orbiters
consciously and subconsciously have used those to attack people,
for instance, like Lav.
Mr. Girl.
Um yeah, a lot of people have attacked those people. Yeah.
I basically just asked like out of the women Destiny's had relationships
with which of them hasn't he tried to, when things go bad, paint
as a mentally ill? Uh probably Erudite. Oh, did that relationship
go bad?
Uh I don't think so. I think they're still friends, but you know,
obviously >> sorry. I I asked when those relationships
go bad, when those people have criticisms for him publicly, which
of those people has he not tried to paint as a mentally ill?
So, not Erudite, obviously, because Erudite doesn't have public
criticisms of him. Well, I don't agree with that. I think in
the in the months ensuing the conversation between her and
Turkey Tom
was not received favorably
either outside of the DGG community or necessarily within it.
So, I mean, the the the relationship was not If you're looking
for more substance, because obviously they didn't have a romantic
relationship. >> no, no. She stood on business to stand
by Destiny when that happened.
Yeah, but do Do you not remember? Maybe Maybe I have a better
memory than everybody, I don't know. Um do you not remember the
part where she was like, "Oh, well, I think this is so messed
up. He needs to be contrite before I'm willing to do a professional
project with him again."
Yeah, which was an obvious lie from her. Obviously. I don't think
that was an obvious lie. I think that was um I think that was
a statement of principle that she wanted to adhere to. Um and
she's largely adhered to it. I don't think that they have worked
on a lot of professional projects together in the past year.
You don't think America is a a professional project they both
work on together? I don't think that's Steven's project. That's
not That's not Steven's project. >> Steven You don't think
Steven is the face of America? You don't think Steven is the
face of America? You don't think Steven is the face of America?
He's one of the faces of America, for sure, but they have like
a lot of years.
>> The most prominent face by far.
I I give Z more I I give Z more credit than that. >> event
was set up by him, right?
Also, I I think Kyle would probably be a part of that with or
without >> Dude, you got to You You be real. You've seen
the videos of Erudite like arguing with people on TikTok that
they should come and join up with Destiny, right? Explicitly
saying Destiny's my business partner, you should come and join
up with him. Uh sorry, say that
You've seen Erudite recruiting for America on TikTok during TikTok
debates going, "Destiny's my business partner. He thinks I'm
really smart. You should come join up."
Come join up and be in this organization with me and Destiny.
I I >> Sorry, you're way out to lunch on this one. I said
specifically that I think Kyla would be a part of America with
or without Steven. Okay, but it's a professional project that
she has advertised as as him being the leader of
Right? It's not the original
>> original point that's being made. You actually went
off on a totally different tangent and said something that's
like totally incorrect.
Like obviously so. >> think it's incorrect at all.
I won't work on him with a on a professional project unless he's
contrite. You think So, that wasn't I will work on him or I will
work on a project with him so long as he's not like leading the
project. That's not what that means, right?
No, but I But I would also say that that what the original thrust
of the the point was not whether or not Erudite was like perfectly
morally
consistent.
The point was was there a person
with which Steven had a tumultuous relationship that he didn't
go both barrels on. And my example was the fact that there was
some tumult
between Kyla and Steven last year, and he didn't go both barrels
on Kyla. That's the point I was making.
Uh I think that's because Kyla was openly like standing up and
saying, "I don't think he's a bad person. I want to stand by
him." It's like not the same thing, right? Is somebody coming
out So, the abusive relationship dynamic I'm talking about, right?
Where somebody comes out and goes, "He was really mean to me.
He like He like did these things that are really bad." And then
he handles that criticism by painting them as a mentally ill.
That didn't happen to Erudite because she didn't do the first
thing. Well, I also don't think that he's called you a mentally
ill. He's just called you mentally ill, right? I said, "Well,
I don't even know if he's done that. He's literally I'm talking
about women. Like obviously there's a relationship dynamic there,
right?
Sure, but I'm I'm just trying to what I'm maybe we should isolate
the variables a little bit then. So, are we talking about exclusively
romantic relationships or or what are we talking
Yeah, usually the romantic relationships are where he does the
mentally ill thing. This is why you you're talking about the
infinite r-machine. I asked where you disagreed, right?
And I said, no, no, no, I think it's pretty obvious that he does
do this thing with people he's had previous relationships with
where when they go bad, he will paint them as a mentally ill.
And I said, who is he not done that with when things have gone
bad publicly?
Yeah, um I I guess the >> Then you but then you said Erudites,
which leads me to believe that you think he Erudites or that
I don't even know. You went on Erudite. I was like totally not
the point of that. >> didn't I didn't assume that we were
talking exclusively about um romantic relationships. I thought
we were talking about all kinds of relationships. If you want
to isolate it down to romantic >> the infinite r-machine,
>> That was the original point. That's where you you brought
it in. And the did your question have specifically only in context
of romantic
I don't think it did.
>> With regards to the infinite r-machine, it does have
to do you mentioned mentally ill. That was part of the >> this
conversation by saying that you were only using the infinite
r-machine and you were attributing it to President Sunday, but
now it sounds like you're arguing for it. And then you gave me
your metaphor, and then I asked you, where do you disagree with
me? And then I said, >> on. Answer answer a direct question,
Jay Stalk. Answer this question direct-o. Do you believe in the
infinite r-machine? Do I believe in the metaphor of people being
harmed and then the normalization of that harm? Yes.
Okay, well, why can't you just say yes? You As a matter of fact,
let me ask you a follow-up question. What's the qualifier that
makes you uncomfortable >> just asked me a question, so
I'm going to answer that first. So, you just asked me, why can't
I just say yes? I can't just say yes because the example you
brought up, I was not talking about like the infinite r-machine
as in Destiny literally r-people, right? So, that's that hyperbole
in the name is what people object to. So, I'm trying to explain
to you that I reject the hyperbole of the name, but not the underlying
concept.
Okay, but I I think I also I I I defined it for you and my definition
didn't include forcible r-either, right? No, it's a conveyor
belt that is audience harasses people, but I think the the orbiters
around that >> Yeah, yeah, I I I think your your addition
was that you didn't think it was so much the audience, you thought
it was the orbiters or you thought it was both. Both. Yeah, it's
like a whole thing where basically people are getting hurt and
Destiny doesn't have to take accountability for any of his own
actions, anything he says or does because he's got a whole machine
of people who will whitewash it for him.
Okay, but I I think we can both both agree that that dynamic
is no longer true, right?
No, just rebuilding with the same same concept, different pieces.
Like like like what? Be because my my thing is if you say Kafka
or
food shops, I don't think these people have anywhere near
of power to to be a force >> multiple times that people
in my community do not deserve moral consideration. Mr. Mouton
said multiple times as a former orbiter of his, Mr. Mouton has
said multiple times that people in my community, people around
me, me myself, you know, we don't deserve moral consideration.
While like an active doxing campaign is taking place from Destiny,
it's him explicitly supporting like doxing, right? That's Dan
and Mouton absolutely a part of that right now.
Whitewashing Destiny's actions, whitewashing Destiny's >> you
correct, you think that he's he's rebuilding the machinery of
the infinite
I think there's just always going to be a financial incentive
because of how big his audience is, how big his reach was, and
how I guess like well-funded his audience is. There'll always
be a monetary advantage to taking his side regardless of how
bad it makes you look.
Okay, so I think I understand your perspective, and that was
the main thrust of what I had for you. But I still had things
for Sunday, Queenman, Lav, Kelly Jean, and Sherry, who I also
feel like were a part of this
drama last spring that I would want to bring up. So, do you want
to keep doing the the clip or do you want to go into that? I
don't particularly want to like I would rather stick to my stuff
cuz I don't really want to speak for other
You don't have to speak for other people, but but I'm I'm telling
you that this is going part of my criticism in this clip is related
to your sphere. And I would consider all the people that I just
that I just cited including
Sunday,
Lav,
Kelly Jean, they were absolutely part of your sphere last year.
Sunday has literally not not hated me for the entirety of the
time we've known each other. So, like I don't know how I could
possibly be responsible for Sunday being in my sphere when Sunday
has literally despised me openly. >> anything about responsibility?
That wasn't my point.
Okay, you just want to you just want to basically make the point
for like Destiny's side.
I want I want to make the I want to make the point that I made
in this clip and I want to make it clear to people what I what
I'm saying. Okay, it might be that I haven't seen the rest of
the clip, so let's watch the rest of the clip here. And cuz I'm
going to have problems with how you characterize my stuff for
sure, but if you're saying that you're not actually saying I'm
responsible for that, you're just saying people around that,
people who don't like Destiny said things and here's how it sort
of added up in >> Well, it's it's the same way that people
hold me responsible for everything that Destiny says even though
I've made it clear dozens of times that this is my perspective.
So, so for instance, like Rile Kitenhouse
is for for lack of a better description in my opinion, he I think
he's your
into YouTube, and he constantly characterizes me as always sleeping
for Steven and always towing the party line, which I don't think
is true at all. So, if I'm going to be held to account where
I'm a part of an orbiter sphere where I am constantly accused
of just being in lockstep with everyone that I associate with,
then yeah, I think that the same dynamic should be especially
if it's somebody that close to you who's making that aesthetic
accusation,
then yeah, I think I should be able to talk to you about the
same thing. I'll speak it clear. Rile's like
but I don't make money from that channel. I literally have told
him like with some things, like I do try to separate from him
in a lot of ways around opinion, but obviously
am very thankful that he puts my stuff on YouTube at all, that
someone's doing that, so it is what it is. I I'm literally okay
with that. You I I'm Yeah, I'm fine with that. What what you
just said I have no >> between you as a creator, Rile as
your editor, all these other creators as other creators, but
I still think that criticizing your sphere as long as I make
that differentiation is valid.
Yeah, I agree with you. We're good. We're good. I'm going to
keep watching the clip. We'll just get through the rest of the
clip and then we can continue this conversation. We'll go through
your notes and stuff.
Cool, cool, cool. Cool, cool. You're not saying cool, but I think
it's cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I wasn't watching the camera. It's my bad.
what what was it? Queenman? Like I know you guys don't believe
me, but I actually do routinely
I routinely watch
Nicholas DeOrio, Chud Logic, and Queenman. I actually rotate
between the three of them for whoever they're making fun of.
What do you watch Nicholas DeOrio for? Be real. Sorry, what's
that? That was low volume. You You watch Nicholas DeOrio for?
Be
I I like Nicholas DeOrio's coverage just
Of what? I'm literally asking of what.
I'm I'm team Ethan, baby. I love the
All right. All right. >> And typically I enjoy their their
going checking live last night where once again Queenman was
one of the hottest out the gate. You know, Steven Steven's a
piece of garbage. He should be held criminally accountable. He
should be held civilly accountable. He he's a dirtbag. He should
[__] this, that, the other. And then last night >> Okay,
wait. where once again Queenman was one of the hottest out the
gate. You know, Steven Steven's a piece of garbage. He should
be held criminally accountable. He should be held civilly
Hold on. You know that Queenman thought Destiny was a piece of
garbage before any of that stuff happened, right? Yeah, of course,
but he came onto my show to say that he was the equivalent of
a I think I'm about to say this. He's the equivalent of a predator
and he should be on a list.
That's what he was saying last year.
Yeah, he is. So, do you think any of those factors that went
into that have been shown to be false? Do you think there's any
reason if you believe that in January of last year, do you think
any evidence has come forward that would change your opinion
on that?
Well, I mean, I think the the fact that Rose was pimped out by
her boyfriend would be something that you should probably talk
about for sure. And then also if that's how you >> any
of us sincerely think Rose was a minor? Hold on. Did When when
you had we had this conversation, did Queenman bring up that
Rose was a minor? Did anyone say Rose was a minor? Or is that
a storyline that only came out in August of this year or something?
>> for the past 6 months where that's been like a huge
thing where it's like, oh, he's a he's a beta. You should be
So, so now that you have This is the This is the crux of the
argument is you now have the people who are at the center
of the infinite r-machine in unsealed depositions ready to go.
It's hot piping content
ready to go. And yet So, just to be clear, you totally shifted.
You totally shifted the point.
So, I just asked you, what changed? What new fact has come out
that changes why Queenman would say he's a predator or why he
should go on a list. You couldn't answer that cuz you started
talking Rose cuz Rose wasn't a part of the calculus for that
at all. Hold on. So, you Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Because I
I think all the facts for last year were also like laughably
small. So, hold on. So, so to be I I need to I need to stop having
you in this argument where it's like, "Okay, well, I didn't say
that." I I need either you to say it or not say it, okay? No,
I said he should be on the
I said he should be on the list. Yeah, I said he should be on
the list.
>> Okay. I Yes. I think I think if you were to have a significant
relationship with Destiny, there's a significant chance that
he would violate your consent in terms of recording you without
your consent or sharing those record sharing record consensually
recorded material without your consent. I think he has a pattern
of doing it and I think he's done it multiple times to the point
where I believe, yes, a list would be appropriate. If you're
going to say that you get targeted for like murder on that list,
then I'm going to go, "Okay, sure." But, I also people who are
on the list have crimes on that list. >> could go to the
fact We could just go to the fact that that's not what the list
is used for. And so, therefore, that feels extremely hyperbolic
that you think that he should be on a Can voyeurs not be on a
offender list?
What's that?
Can voyeurs not be on a sex offender
No, voyeurs can be on the sex offender list. But, guess what?
The This was what I was going to bring up in reference to Sherry.
So, Sherry's accusation
was that they had a consensual encounter, I don't know, a year
ago, 2 years ago, or whatever, that it was audio recorded without
her consent, that she was filing a police report with her local
jurisdiction, that she was going to be prosecuting, and that
she was coordinating with the detective. Where's that case? Why
do you think it would be public? Why do you think it's not being
investigated? Because it's been a what?
No update? No nothing? Yeah.
Yeah. So, So, hold on. Do you think Wait, do you think that doesn't
happen? Do you think Do you think
>> Do you think police don't do that? >> how how
come he hasn't been charged? How many updates Can I ask you how
many updates happened on the Russell Brand case from the accusation
happening to when he was
I have no idea. I haven't followed the Russell Brand case. >> Well, the
answer is zero. Oh, wait. Hold on. So, you just want me to take
it on
>> that was more than a year ago. Hold on. I didn't ask
you Wait, did I ask you to take it on faith?
Did I ask you to take it on faith? >> that this is going
in the background. You're asking You're asking
the audience and you're asking me to take it on faith that there
is a digital voyeurism case
in the background that's still running, that's being criminally
prosecuted. I think Yeah, I think you're asking us to take that
on faith.
I don't I Again, I don't know anything about it. I only know
what she said
Okay. So, if you only know what you think what she said publicly
>> a police report was filed and the case was closed
Uh-huh. In Florida, you'd be able to find that, right?
Uh yeah. I think in the state of Florida, there's a public records
act where if I knew her real name, which I'm not really going
to go out of my way to find, but if I knew her real name and
it was filed in the state of Florida, I think I could probably
find it.
Okay. That You understand that's not a resolution, right?
can't say anything else. You just haven't really looked into
it, which is I could talk to you off stream about it or something.
I I won't even talk to you off stream about it. I'm trying not
to talk about any of that stuff.
Okay. So, hold hold on. So, do you Do you want to keep going
with the clip or do you want to Do you want to go to nuts? >> We can
keep going with with the clip, but just so you know, there are
also clearly like pocket recorded recordings of Destiny with
Grinder hookups that there's no he has not provided a compelling
reason for existing or how the the clip like proceeds.
Right? So, there's there's clips of him with clearly his phone
in his pocket. He said he kept he admitted his phone is in his
pocket the whole time. And he said he did that because the other
person didn't want their face to be recorded. In that same clip
you can hear him pull his phone out and start like fiddling with
it sort of breaking that person's request, which is don't have
the phone out while we're doing something. Right? It doesn't
make any sense. His explanation makes no sense.
Okay. I I will come back >> There's multiple
previously recorded materials within like the leaks that happened
with him. Just saying. Uh Okay. So, so you think that he should
Just to Just to re-summarize, you think that he should be on
the sex offenders registry uh because digital voyeurism is a
thing. But, hold on. Hold on. I I I've told you I've told you
I've told you >> I've told you I've told you I've told
you Wait, wait, wait. Don't Don't Don't
Just I'm just explaining. I already told you why I think he should
be on the like predator list or whatever the >> Yes, because
he violates people's consent. Uh he has a propensity for recording
people without their consent. He has a propensity for distributing
recordings of people that have been made consensually without
their consent. Oh, and non-consensually recorded materials without
their consent, too. Okay. So, so hold on. He has a propensity
for distributing material without with or without the consent
of the person involved.
Okay. So, I want to I want to nail this down and make it specific.
Okay? So, Okay. if I'm hearing your position correctly you're
stating Steven should be on the sex offender registry
for uh effectively digital voyeurism
but since digital voyeurism involves video he should be on the
registry effectively for like a wiretapping
violation because he audio recorded people without their consent.
>> Uh yeah, that he's recording
like literally just encounters without people's consent.
I understand that I don't know a lot. By the way, I literally
said when I said this at the time that I don't know the legal
code in Florida, that I don't think you could necessarily like
I don't know if you could defend this by the legal code. I think
because this person is Well, wiretapping is the literal definition.
It's a little thing that you would do this under in Florida.
But, I'm saying I don't I When I said that, I didn't know the
laws. I was just saying that I believe personally
that when you're going to record people without their consent
in a situation,
that your future partner should be warned about that. That you
have a propensity to do that. >> And just to be clear,
you you weren't crazy. That that was not the craziest take because
when I was looking up the law, which by the way, I've had like
a video essay on this for like a year um the the digital voyeurism
facts um is a certain statute, but it involves video, whereas
wiretapping statute covers audio recordings without the person's
consent.
To be clear, I also when LegalMindset did his video on like Destiny's
case originally, I called out that he got the digital voyeurism
statute incorrect.
Like that is literally the number one thing when when Qman and
I have talked about LegalMindset, that's the number one thing
we point to in terms of him being a complete is how he explained
digital voyeurism in the in regards to Destiny's case.
Okay. Then then I'm I'm happy to proceed with the clip, I suppose.
Okay. he's
a dirt bag. He should [__] This, that, the other.
And then last night when, you know, once again, huge opportunity
to make money, huge opportunity for viewership, huge opportunity
to to fight people.
And he was like, "Nah, I'm going to cover 2-year-old Mizkif drama."
And it's like, "Where's this heat?"
Wait, what?
I didn't Wait, when did I cover the Mizkif thing?
No, that's Qman.
Oh, I see. Where Where's this heat? Wait, wait. Wait, was Qman
live yesterday? Uh it was Yeah, I'm like 90% sure that last night
he was live and he was covering old Mizkif Mizkif drama.
Oh. And this was this was also after the Rose thing. And And
I think the reason why I said this specifically
was because he had so much heat for me the day after the day
after on January 21st, 2020
five. Uh okay. All right.
That's Sorry, I'm like caught off guard cuz I literally didn't
realize that Miz was or sorry, that Qman was live yesterday covering
[__] I'm just very confused. I thought he was like
doing [__] and Sorry, I When I have a fact get this
place in my head, I like lose my mind. That's my bad. But, I
I get it that he was like had heat for you and he wasn't covering
this. I don't think anybody So, I think Qman's opinion I don't
have to say I think. I know Qman's opinion is Destiny fell off
super hard and that building anything around him the the amount
of viewership you get for covering any of his stuff uh is totally
massively outweighed by how much harassment you get from him
and his community. And so, there's just no reason to cover it
anymore. Do you disagree with that?
Uh I mean, that that could be true, but the the fell off >> That
is factual. The the the fell off thing though, well, then that
that's >> you to agree that he fell off. I don't need you
to agree that he fell off. Just agree it's disproportionate.
Basically, you don't get enough views to make it worth the harassment
you get from him and his audience. >> on. The I remember
No, I that that's actually a part that I can agree with. In 2022
it was a peak day to be at 11K with Lav on the stream.
I think a year ago, probably when all of this dropped, he was
bouncing between 10 and 15. He's still bouncing between five
and 10. So, if he's bouncing and half of and half of his content
is gone. He's like playing Arc Raiders a majority of the time
since he got demonetized on YouTube. So, how can you say that
he fell off if he's getting numbers similar to when you were
originally covered?
I literally just said I don't have to I just said what I thought
the opinion was, but I literally don't care. I actually don't.
Like I I don't care to argue that he fell off. I don't I don't
I literally don't care. >> Oh, sorry. I misunderstood.
My apologies. That's why I said I just just That's why I said
I don't need to argue the fell off point cuz I understand you're
his friend, you don't want to say that. It's whatever. It's not
a big deal to me. I was just repeating what I'd heard, which
was like it's literally just not worth it to cover this this
Um Well, unfortunately
>> I just want to know, can I can I get it on the record
that both you and Destiny are requesting
that I cover because I I basically put it out there as a question
yesterday. Whatever gets fewer people doxxed, I will do. If if
covering this is going to get more people doxxed, I will literally
cover it. If if not Okay, cuz I just I want to know. I'm just
trying to minimize the amount of harm that's done to like my
community from his community. So like, if I could I'm trying
to negotiate with the terrorists, right? So if I if I cover
This is the richest point, though. You're you're kind of proving
me wrong and him right
in in this scenario because effectively >> Ow. Go ahead.
>> If what you're because I said I said you cannot hold
Jstark and Queenman accountable for the schizophrenics on Kiwi
Farms. You should not be digitally harassing and doxxing them
as a result of what may be may be some alleged cross-pollination
from their audience into Kiwi Farms is doing. You can't punish
them from for the sins of the collective. And yet, you're saying
that Steven has achieved the goal that he set out to achieve,
which was to have you and Queenman and other quote-unquote anti-fans
cover him less. So you basically just said that the doxx war
worked.
Yeah, like I don't get anything out of covering him. I don't
get more viewers out of covering him. Why would I cover him?
By the way, it didn't work on me or like like when he was starting
to doxx me, I was like, oh, [__] that. Now he's starting
to doxx random unrelated people. Starting to doxx Wicked Supreme.
He's doxxed Esports Batman. Right? Like that Now I'm like, oh,
well, now you're just going after people adjacent to me. Now
that you are explicitly doing the Kiwi Farms tactics to me, I'm
like, oh, I'll actually whatever I can do to not get the people
around me harassed, that's actually what I'll do. I'm literally
saying, hey, you won. You you're you're bluffed now. You won.
You're bluffed now. Yeah, you're you're bluffed now. So you you
won. What can I do to not get the people around me harassed and
doxxed?
Okay. I mean, yeah, that By the way, totally totally made up
the his entire pretext for doing this in the first place was
entirely made up. Right? But unfortunately, nobody around him
would stand on principle and say, well, I'm not going to be around
you while you're doing this. So I I literally have nothing to
do except move on, right?
What What is Unless you Do you have a better option? What do
you think the better option is? >> I genuinely don't. I
I just
I'm I'm I'm finding many things ironic right now.
Sure, go ahead. What's What's the irony?
No, the the irony is that I was over here saying like you stop
punishing Queenman and Jstark for the sins of alleged cross-pollinators
in their community. >> is that Wait, why is that ironic?
Yeah, it worked. We're going to stop covering him. Yeah, well,
sorry, if he showed up to my house and killed me, it would also
work. It would still be bad. You would still be right to tell
him not to do that, right? Okay, sure. I used a bad example.
Like there are things you could do to threaten people that wouldn't
send you to prison that are like [__] up. It doesn't
mean it's wrong to criticize him for that. I'm saying that yeah,
it worked as in like basically, I don't get enough additional
views to cover him
to make him doxxing my community and trying to kill my community
worth it.
I I'm not I'm not going to argue that you should like take up
the banner of the crusade in order to commit digital through
digital harassment on some principle.
Uh I just I I do find this ironic that I was just arguing with
him within the past 6 months saying, hey, you're a [__]
when you're doing this [__] and you're [__]
digitally harassing people. And then I come to the people who
are allegedly being digitally harassed. And they're saying, no,
it worked. Did you tell him it didn't work? Did you tell him
it worked? Uh I don't I don't know if I told him it didn't work.
I don't remember my exact phrasing. I was saying it was bad.
>> ironic What's ironic about it? If it was true And and
by the way, I'm saying if it's true because I I don't know it
to be true. I do not have a line of facts. If it was true that
Let Let's say that we Let's use stochastic
uh stochastic logic for a second. >> be clear, when you
go if it were true, when the facts are readily readily accessible,
you are entertaining the idea that you should take this person's
word for it. Right? That you should just take their word for
it when they say something. You are You are because you're entertaining
You're allowing the harm to continue. You're not You're not actually
You can't do anything about the harm. Like realistically, what
I think would help Destiny, what you guys should have done to
try to help him, was to say, I'm not going to be around you if
you're going to engage in this, right? That's like as friends,
you guys should have been doing >> gets to have his cake
and eat it, too. Now he gets his orbiters and you and Queenman
stop covering him because the the benefit to harassment ratio
is off.
Well, well, hold on. Can Can I articulate this even if you don't
agree with it, okay? Yeah, sure. >> So So So the stochastic
calculus, which by the way, once again, it's like for me, it's
like touching the poo. I don't I don't want to be involved in
this Um so I don't touch the poo. But the the stochastic rhetoric
that Steven assigned to you and to Queenman was effectively,
they're logging the [__] out of me, they're covering
the [__] out of me, the same kind of person who has
a profile in Jstark and Queenman and Spicy Chats Discords or
whatever are the same kind of people that are on 4chan, Kiwi
Farms, and Doxbin. And apparently, there's a new website. Um
and so as a result,
>> on. I just I You just mentioned Doxbin. But realistically,
they know that there's a lot of cross-pollination between these
communities. That's it. That That That was the idea of the argument.
It's It's literally like not about cross-pollination is like
a stupid argument, right? It's about what the person can know
and what they can control. If If people if there were some cross-pollination,
which there's cross-pollination between all of the communities,
okay? But like if there were cross-pollination, it's about what
I can control. Who do I know who has accounts on both places
that I could ban, right? Like what can I actually do about it?
Because otherwise, what what the like I guess recommendation
with the prescription is is don't be mean to Destiny because
other people don't like him. And you're supporting those people
by being mean to That's what he's trying to control, right? Don't
be mean to him. >> incorrect to hold you to try to hold
you digitally accountable for the sins of others. You thought
it was. It's still obviously morally incorrect, yes?
Yeah. Okay. That You You understand that morally incorrect actions
can be effective like good decisions for somebody. >> Oh,
for sure. Like you said, if someone murders you, you're still
you're you've been stabbed, >> Guys. right? So So even
if it So that's my whole thing is you're like, oh, it's ironic.
I was arguing he shouldn't be doing this. And it's like, no,
he like he can do this. And if nobody's going to hold him
But like what I would say is the dogged underdog wins. May Maybe
I've seen too many Marvel films.
What I would say is as somebody around Destiny, you should probably
not want him to do this because he's basically arguing that be
by being around him right? Sorry, by being around people who
do bad things, you are responsible for those bad things. And
you are around somebody who's engaging in a doxxing and harassment
campaign trying to get people doxxed and harassed, right? So
you are yourself signing up to be around someone who is doxxing
and harassing people while arguing that you are responsible for
that doxxing and harassment if you hang around that person. So
you are opting in to being doxxed and harassed yourself almost
by definition, right?
I I Hold on. The The part that all I think is logical that you
just said is that through proximity
if that person is engaged in that moral calculus, then I am potentially
a target. But I also think that I am one of the few people in
this space who's consistently advocating against that
Sure, you're advocating against it while reaping the rewards.
>> me 100%. They can say, well, you're too close to Steven,
[__] you. I'm going to doxx you anyways. I don't
care what you say. Yeah, that's 100% possible. >> But you
you understand that you have no position to like
you have no position to like opt to to go to other people and
say, isn't this like horrible?
Right? Cuz you've you've opted into hang around somebody who
who advocates for >> Yeah, I'll try not to complain too
much. If it actually results in in a real world consequence,
I'll try not to complain too much.
Okay. So that's more of what I'm like I'm sitting here and I'm
like, well, I can see that this works against like tiny communities
that you could try to bully away, right? But eventually, he's
going to upset the wrong people. And eventually, he's going to
get into a fight with like the wrong people in a way bigger sense,
like someone like Asmongold, and this will all be true still,
right? That he is engaged in this stuff and he has greenlit attacks
on all of his friends in this way.
And I'm just like, oh, that's obviously bad. So while I might
not want to cover this anymore, while I might want to like relax
my coverage and move on cuz I don't have a big enough community
to deal with this guy trying to explicitly go and doxx random
community members of
Right? Like I probably can't run a busi- Like just imagine if
you had like a like an Asmongold or a Vaush who is consistently
going to your Discord looking for anybody them and then trying
to doxx them. Do you think that'd have a negative effect in your
community? Oh, yeah, of course.
Yeah, so it's like I just don't have a big enough community where
I can like
handle that consistently and still be like a streamer, maintain
that
No, I'm
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I think I probably just made a a classic
uh a classic thought mistake of mistaking like moral correctness
with effectiveness, I suppose. Okay. Okay, fair enough. Yeah.
Yeah, and so
I'm kind of like shocked that I think a morally unjust action
is effective. But I But I also think that Steven would effectively,
you know, find
a justification
>> for why he's still correct. And then but also cite the
effectiveness
of why he should continue in what I view as morally objectionable
behavior. It's particularly crazy to me that you didn't think
about it cuz that's the entire Trump admin. It's like how your
entire conservative movement got derailed in the United States,
right? Well, I mean I'm I'm losing on that side too, right? I'm
I'm still constantly appealing to what I think is correct and
I have a
I have a very intelligent and very
community.
But I still have a very small community because I don't
engage in the same tactics that seem to be profiting everybody
else. Um Okay. So being a being a virtuous loser is kind of a
theme.
Uh yeah, I mean principles cost you stuff, right?
Principles don't tend to be like literally having no principles
the best way to operate in the world, the most efficient. It's
just that they all they only cost you things. They don't they
they never like help. All right, at least I don't they help it's
like exceedingly rare when they help, okay? I I I don't know
if that's entirely true. I think that the the quality of people
that you attract is higher
if you if you failingly espouse and try to follow a code.
I think the quality of people you attract is better.
Okay. But but but you're right that like non-virtuous people
who virtue signal at the top of social hierarchies and seem to
have no principles besides whatever's in vogue at the time. Those
seem seem to be the people who profit the most and rise to the
top the fastest.
Yeah, and basically the entire argument I hear is Destiny is
precisely one of those people. There's a ton of evidence he's
one of those people. He probably it's probably like harmful to
have him at the front of a political movement especially given
his propensity to put himself above that movement at all times.
But but they maybe this is a totally different argument so maybe
we should set it up for a different time. But the I think Steven
is like a a genuine advocate for the liberal ideology even he
uses it as an excuse to be a nihilist hedonist. But that's because
that's like the governmental system that condones
and to some degree even endorses
his libertine lifestyle.
Whereas a lot of a lot of other
political belief systems would actually condemn it. And when
he's like advocating for ICE to deport Pixie's wife, you think
that's a part of like I think that's just like you think that's
like I think that's just viciousness. Yeah, so like you could
say it's about the hedonist lifestyle, but I'm pointing to like
actual things that you just ignore when you like make these statements
Um I I don't think he whether or not he believes in liberalism
has anything to do with having personal vendetta against someone
and try to take them out. Try to use like literally the the Trump
administration on ICE to get her taken out. You don't think that's
like hypocrisy? You don't think seeing Okay, you don't think
him going and doing the calculus of well, Trump's ICE seems to
be like way overstepping their bounds. I'm going to report this
person to ICE. You don't think that flies in the face of a lot
of the things he stands for?
Well, I think this is actually a conversation that I was having
with a political advocate earlier today
that liberalism actually makes very little moral judgment about
people's behavior under the political system. That arguably like
neoliberalism within the past like 40 or 50 years has tried to
eschew
like moral considerations and instead just say here's the political
system under which we all play. And as long as you like pay your
taxes, nobody gives a [__] You you So you're saying
like liberalism is just immoral. There's no moral considerations
in liberalism at all. >> I think there's branches of liberalism
that do. The the guy that I was talking to at the chance of getting
him involved in [__] he does want to be involved
in was Ryan Gedi, r y a n g e d d i e. And he seems like a pretty
well-read fellow. And he actually says like no, this is the antithesis
of what liberalism used to be. Liberalism used to say that the
virtues of the populace you have to have socio-cultural prescriptions
or else this entire system falls apart. But within the past 40
to 50 years,
it seems like liberal politics has
eschewed that responsibility.
Okay. I And again, you could talk about like the the system overall.
I don't think again, I I feel like you're just dodging the point,
which is No no, I'm not. Destiny makes all these criticisms of
Trump's ICE and then he goes and tries to weaponize
it in the like in the direct in this direct way. Like honestly,
probably the best way for me to go after Destiny let me just
probably the best way for me to go after Destiny would be to
collect all the stuff I've like learned about him and then go
to somebody who's involved with the Republican government. It
wouldn't take that long, not that many hops and try to get that
into the hands of like J.D. Vance who's expressed some want to
prosecute this guy, right?
Yeah. That would probably be the best way to hurt this person,
right? If you wanted to do maximum damage, sure. That that probably
would be the most effective way to do it. >> If I wanted
to actually act, hold on. If I wanted to do tit for tat as in
like hey, I want to go like basically some of the time eye for
an eye, this would be one of the eye for the eye eye for an eye
cases. If I wanted to report him to some extremely
authoritarian form of US government or some some US politician
who's an authoritarian
who has a vendetta against him, right?
If I wanted to do the same thing as what he's doing to Pixie,
trying to report his Pixie's wife >> about to say I was
about to ask is he doing it to you or is he doing that to
He's doing it to Pixie.
Is Pixie a part of your tribe or either political or social?
>> I would say yeah, by being like like essentially doxxed
and harassed by Destiny, yeah, sure.
Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That then all I was going to point out
is that like tit for tat is typically reserved for rival tribes,
I suppose. Either like individual tit for tat or rival tribes.
Sure. I mean I again, I haven't done that because I do think
that that would be like the wrong way to win. Sure. I don't think
going to like I don't think going to people I think are trying
to destroy
the world essentially. Like they are they are literally corrosive
to the planet. I don't think going to them to try to get when
they hate somebody to try to get like that person like in legal
trouble, I don't think that's the way you approach that. I think
that's wrong. Sure. No, I know. I agree. The as a matter of fact,
you would say at a minimum Pixie could do it, right? Yeah. Yeah,
yeah,
I think Pixie could say that well, he says that he's going to
go after me both barrels in every way possible. So I'm going
to go after him both barrels every way possible.
Hold on. I I did want to make this point though. That part of
the reason why your criticism where you're saying like okay,
I should gather up all this ammunition. And I'm not saying you're
going to do this. I'm just saying hypothetically.
Hypothetically, you should gather up all this information.
You should give it to the person who has the most potential to
do damage and then turn it over to them and then hope that they
do the damage that you think is reciprocal to the way that Steven's
operating in the world. One of the things that I think is happening
that actually points to a lack of moral concern for the the behavior
of individuals over the past 40 or 50 years actually is the way
that the alternative media currently operates. Because for instance,
like Tim Pool with Ten Minute Media, that should have been a
death knell for his career. It probably dented it proverbially
it dented his car. It did not do anything. Same thing with Hasan
[__] I think the I'm pretty sure Tim Pool's [clears throat]
fallen off
Yeah, so so the broad point is that in the modern media landscape,
it actually probably doesn't matter how morally nefarious you
are on an individual level. What matters more is whether or not
you can get clout, eyeballs, click clicks, and a message. >> Oh,
yeah, sure. Yeah, 100%.
Well, but what you said earlier is that Steven is inherently
poison for any moment movement that he's a part of. But what
I would say is that as long as he's getting clicks, views, and
able to spread ideas, people will use him. Um
People will use him, but it's about like whether it's about like
how good that is, right? Like I think a lot of people in the
conservative movement move away from Tim Pool
basically probably not on moral grounds, given he's just like
kind of poison in a lot of ways. I think
Basically, what you have to accept here is that Destiny's moved
from being like a moral arbiter, how a lot of people looked at
him, right? To being more of a like an entertainer who people
will use in the same way you'd use any entertainer. The same
way you'd use any entertainer. >> a question?
Go ahead. Um so in reference to Rose, because this was one of
my arguments that I kind of got made fun of last last year for.
I was saying that like listen, I object to crazy [__]
that Steven does all the time, whereas it seems like other people
do not share the same objections and yet they're willing to say
he's like the most like villainous piece of [__]
person on the planet. So here here's my question.
If Rose had been 18 years old and 1 day and if the leaks had
not happened,
how
would you I guess number one, would you care? And I guess the
follow-up is to what degree would you care?
The leaks had not happened. >> out on a personal level,
but it wasn't
On a personal level if I was shared all of the details,
uh I would probably just look schizophrenic. I don't know exactly
what I would do, but like I would obviously
I would think the guy's like a horrible person for like all of
the things that I've heard about. Um but I don't know so if you're
saying oh, I only know it on a personal level, I can't prove
it to other people." then I No, no, no, no, no. I I would say
you have like perfect knowledge of all of Steven's foibles and
flaws.
But we we didn't have the the fall out from destroying relationships
and, you know, public embarrassment and all that
Yeah, so I would say that I didn't know I knew about the leaks
and I didn't think that was something he should be destroyed
over because I wasn't sure if like the degree it went to, how
bad it was. I was willing to give him the benefit of the doubt.
And then when I realized that it was actually like it went deeper
than I thought, that he'd done more and worse than I thought,
then it suddenly flipped and I went from, "Oh, this guy was taking
advantage of me like trying to paint himself as a victim." And
like I was totally bought into that. I was like trying to help
him. I was trying to explain like, "Hey, like here's all my my
texts with this Solo guy like from my my Discord logs. Have it
all like I'm sorry this is happening to you. It really sucks."
when it was just the Lauren texts to like, "Oh, well, the Pixy
[__] came out. That's kind of weird. I guess I'll
wait to see on this." to then I learned that he was recording
people without their consent. And realistically, I was probably
just ideologically or I don't know, monetarily blinded in some
way. Realistically, just the Grindr recordings were enough to
probably say he was recording without consent. But I didn't I
didn't want to accept that at the time. And I don't know if that's
blindness from like this person's my friend. I don't know if
that's blindness from I'm making a lot of money from being in
this community and streaming right now. I don't know what exactly
that was.
like I I do think that
given if I could know all of the stuff, I still would react the
same way. I still would like I might not be able to do like the
the content in the same way. I don't know.
But I I do think I would react in roughly the same way on a personal
level.
No, I I I I I I hope that's true. Um the >> I think. I
don't even have to say I think. I don't have to hedge there.
I would have 100% react the exact same way on a personal level
reality. I just the reason why I was
is because I think there there there's a lot of sweepers and
there are a lot of anti-fans who like to jump in whenever I call
whenever I cover Steven stuff. And I think one of my frustrations
is I I would say that I probably have like a 60/40 split between
conservative and libertarian types that are the 40% and I would
say like tough liberals is probably 60% of my audience. And the
amount of degeneracy that we fight over routinely is actually
almost like shocking. And I would say that for some of the sweepers
and for the some of the haters, if the leaks hadn't occurred
and if Rose was 18 years and 1 day old, they wouldn't have cared.
They wouldn't have cared at all. And I find that >> Yeah, again.
shocking sometimes.
Um at that time,
I didn't think Rose was a minor. When I when I originally went
through this, I did not believe Rose was a minor. Now, there's
a difference between not believing somebody is a minor
when you're told and basically saying, "I think you're lying
about her being a minor, so I'm going to retain multiple videos
of her." There's a big difference between those two steps, but
I didn't think she was a minor. I would never have tried to I
would never have tried to say, "Oh, well, I'm going to roll the
dice on whether or not this is cease
I would never personally done that, but again, I none of none
of like the Rose is a minor stuff was even a part of my original
calculus. So the idea that people are bringing that up is if
like, "Oh, well, we've proven that Rose was like actually sex
trafficked and even though she was a minor, she was sex trafficked."
Like this changes nothing from the original
at all. I think the I I think the point there though and and
I was actually I was going to ask you that >> You can make
this point. I have to walk away for 30 seconds. I'm still listening
to you though, okay? I'll be right back. Okay. So I I think the
point there though that the sweepers are arguing with which I
kind of want to hear your response to is that the original accusation
by combining the quote unquote infinite rate machine by
what what was the other point? By saying that he belongs on a
list and that he's a predator and this that the other and all
that kind of stuff. Well, all of that is actually true of Solo.
And so if it's true that Rose was actually
a girl who was being trafficked by this guy who was threatening
her, who was in a different community, who knew her age and misrepresented
it and lied, then it feels like it shifts a lot of the malevolence
from Steven to Solo. And so I I guess that's
kind of what I hear argued and I want to hear your response to
it. Yeah, I didn't like this Solo guy from the first time I ever
talked to him. He was like a weird anime freak who's like trying
to do anime villain monologues in
in like DMs with people with both me and Destiny and I think
Sunday too. He was like trying to play like some kind of puppet
master. He's just like a weird gross freak. And I've never liked
this guy. I've wanted this guy to be like gone after basically
since it was confirmed that Rose was a minor. Well, right. So
so hold on. That's okay. Hold on. I have no I have no private
information on him. I've never had private information on him.
I don't go and look for this stuff like despite what people say.
I've never gone and looked for this stuff. It's not my responsibility.
The person who had private information who could do something
was Destiny the whole time.
Well, so so hold on. I I want to ask you a slightly different
question, but it's still relevant. The
So looking at these two guys who I think you view both of them
as villains because you actually said, "If I if I had a friend
like this and it was a personal thing and I knew it perfectly,
but it wasn't all public, I would still view this person as garbage
and I probably, you know, I think you effectively said that you
wouldn't interact with them anymore and you would probably treat
them similarly."
>> depending on how much you could prove. Like if I could
prove literally nothing, I don't know if I do content the same
way cuz then I would just look like a schizophrenic, right? >> But
but but I'm more talking about like your guys' relationship,
I suppose. That's what I'm asking about. Yeah.
so when when it comes to the villainy because I do think like
villainy is on a
Um how in your mind do you compare the villainy of Solo compared
to the villainy of Steven? Like like um I I would argue that
Solo is a worse person for XYZ ABC reasons.
Um but I but I kind of just want to hear your gut reaction. Sure.
Um so who's a worse person?
Who's done worse crimes? >> And to and to what degree?
But but there's like a whole different thing here, right? There's
like a whole different thing of how I liked Destiny. I thought
he was a good person. Then I found out that he was not a good
person, that he was using this whole thing, these like liberal
politics, his whole like red pill arc as basically a way to meet
women, get into relationships with them and then
do whatever he wanted, not really care or believe principally
in any of those things. He's basically just lying about like
what he believed to get laid and or get material from people
and sharing it around and just trying to like build this whole
thing in the background, right? Like I think I think that's a
particularly despicable thing. Can I say I think that's why uh
I I wasn't as shocked and maybe I wasn't as crazy because we
we always had memes. I gave you an Andrew Wilson like this point.
I was like, "If you want to
Yeah, if you want to defend Destiny on the lines of like every
person who's a victim of him should have known he was like a
weird consent violating freak from the beginning. If that's the
point you wanted to stand on, no, that was the point you and
Andrew Wilson were standing on. You just don't want to admit
it now. It's literally why you're so excited right now to make
this point. We had all the evidence in the world to say this
guy was probably a weird disgusting like consent violating freak.
And it's the women's fault. If you wanted to say that, then I'm
like, "Okay, you're already admitting the core premise, so thank
you."
Well, ho- ho- hold on. Do you think that the
Do you think a guy
who he is maybe through hyperbole
in order to have sex
is like akin to
like either like either a a forcible
or a drug
No, the consent violations are what make him like more equivalent
to that in the digital sense. >> I'm sorry. Can Can I ask
you how old are
How old are Approximately. Like late 20s, early 30s?
I said 30. >> Late 30s? Early 30s.
I just turned 30. Just go. Okay, just turned 30. Okay. Okay.
That's that's it. I don't want to say that on stream, okay? That's
rough for me. Jesus Christ,
Go ahead. [laughter] Okay, the the only reason why I'm asking
is just because I think a If you go back and you look at the
sex rom-coms and I'm not excusing it. I'm not defending it. Defending
it sounds like I endorse it. I don't endorse it. Not endorsing
the behavior. I'm describing it. >> Yeah. Okay?
I just want you to understand that the consent violations are
my problem, right? But I do think it's broadly disgusting for
somebody I believed in in terms of political goals, political
projects to be lying about their beliefs both in terms of relationships,
about politics, right? In order to sell this stuff, presenting
themselves as someone who could lead this movement and they don't
sincerely believe the things they say they do.
Well, well, ho- hold up. So so do you think that >> kind
of like scummy I don't want to be around this guy.
Do you think there can be a good a good message from a bad messenger?
Uh yeah, there can be a good message from a bad messenger, but
unfortunately, once you've identified that person as a terrible
messenger, in fact, somebody who's willing to aggrandize themselves
at the cost of that movement, then I think you need to get rid
of that
Uh I'm not going to lie. I kind of
I actually didn't like the red pill arc, so I didn't engage with
a lot of
So is there something particularly egregious from the red pill
arc that you feel is like a very
uh specific
that just like gets your just gets your goat?
Sorry, you got to ask that again. I got a donation there right
at the exact time you were speaking. Sorry, sorry, sorry. >> I
was asking
I've always been skeptical
of the liberal egalitarian feminist.
I looked at the anti-misogyny
and the those perspectives as typically
a a strategy to seem attractive to women. And so so I didn't
take it um I always viewed it that way. And so my question to
you is you're saying that there was something that he advocated
for within his political and social advocacy
that so clearly was hypocritical in the light of what happened
last year that you could no longer look at him as the same person.
So what I'm asking you is
Yeah, there's a perfect there's a perfect microcosm of this that
when when basically somebody would accuse a man of some impropriety
or some wrongdoing Byron would go oh this is a gold digging
And Destiny would go no no no no you have to understand like
where they're coming from and stuff. But then when Pixie files
her lawsuit now suddenly she's a gold digging who's trying to
[__] her way up the ladder, okay? And Destiny's the
person who wronged her. But now Pixie's a gold digging who's
trying to [__] her way up the ladder. YOU ARE THE
ONE YOU ARE YOU STUPID
RIGHT? SO YEAH, that is obvious clear hypocrisy that I'm like
oh you're like a disgusting loser. You're not a good leader of
any movement. You're just a totally hypocritical who shouldn't
be listened to. Okay.
Um that >> You disagree with any of that? By the way Well,
I I >> I assume he assumes you're his friend. But you know
who else was your friend?
Lauren Southern who has just openly lied to you. This This guy
was literally saying oh I'm I like kind of I don't I feel really
I feel you're really special and and I want to be with you Lauren,
right? You're friends with Lauren. He was lying to Lauren openly.
He was literally discussing getting butt plugs with a 22-year-old
man that he thought was an 18-year-old girl. And leaking all
of these DMs that he had with Lauren to this girl. >> Um
I'm sorry. Are you saying >> Sorry, man that he thought
was a girl. The the the butt plug thing was Rose?
Yes. Which was apparently solo.
I didn't know that detail. >> but he was literally leaking
the relationship DMs with Lauren telling Lauren he was going
to change he was going to be better. He was flirting with Christianity,
right? And he's just lying. He's like openly lying about all
>> self-deluding and in love in that regard? Okay, where's
the self-deluding and in love part where he's literally like
leaking all of these DMs to the 18-year-old sex worker >> I
think that was after that was after. Right? That was after the
relationship had imploded, right? >> during. It was before
the relationship had to fully imploded. He was literally discussing
going to meet up with Lauren. With this person. Okay. The my
No, I suppose I do not sign a sign may maybe I should check the
messages myself, but I don't I don't assign that level of malevolence
maybe because
um Wait, when I say malevolence it's
I I look at the outcomes, right? Like he he literally
didn't he was lying to Lauren. He was not trying to sincerely
change anything about himself. He was discussing all the sexual
degeneracy that was making Lauren concerned with this 18-year
sorry, with the 22-year-old man that he thought was an 18-year-old
sex worker who he was catfished with by Sorry, he was catfished
by that 22-year-old man with the pictures of a minor who was
sex trafficked at the time. Sorry, I it's hard to get this whole
thing straight. Right? But he was basically discussing the whole
breakup with Lauren. He's discussing all his sexual He was it's
engaging extremely degenerate behavior, right? While trying to
convince Lauren that like he could be the guy who takes care
of her and her her son. Like to me if I were Lauren's friend
I would go oh you're a real piece of [__] But I don't
know what you do. I don't know how you handle that. Apparently
you handle it by putting your head in the sand and not reading
the messages in Well, I also think that's their private business,
but I mean I've talked to um not recently
not recently um but I've talked to both
parties about their perception of the >> Cuz yeah, yeah,
maybe I'm wrong cuz apparently Lauren has no problem with that.
Apparently Lauren Southern's super chill with that. So maybe
maybe I'm getting the wrong impression. >> no no no no
there's this Hold on. I I don't think this is fair.
the I I was commenting on the fact that they were back together
and hanging out or something. I was just saying Well, no that's
that's that's what I was going to comment on. So so once again
I I don't think I I think I've already made or I made a mistake
previously
um speaking for them and I shouldn't speak for them at all. I
can tell you my vibes. Um my vibes
are that I think that both of them uh vacillated
in a very serious and extreme relationship and it's actually
quite obvious that they genuinely cared for each other a lot.
And it was because they were who they were which I I would say
it was almost laughably predictable
um that it wouldn't work out, but I I still think that there
was there was something real there I guess is what I'm trying
to say. >> I believe that. >> There was definitely
something real
on both sides. >> Yeah, I believe that. I believe that.
Do you think >> Yeah, so Do you think you could have real
feelings for somebody and
and still be lying to them? >> I can be a little bit graceful
with my judgment I suppose. The reason why I don't judge that
harshly is because like I've been through real things in the
real things were messy and gross and messed up and weird. And
that's happened. And by the way like I'm I'm not saying this
as an attack at all. A lot of people were attacking your relationship
with Sherry and I was saying like no that's totally unfair. Like
these people have been friends they've been through a lot together.
They share like the digital community
and sometimes even if it's not like the perfect moral calculation
you develop feelings for people. And so that that's part of the
Yeah, so so that that's where for me it's like um I don't just
extend that grace to Steven. I You think I'm saying he's like
totally Machiavellian like liar like scumbag who is just trying
to manipulate Lauren for some like end goal of some kind. No,
I think there were feelings there sure. I don't I don't think
he like didn't care about this person at all. Okay. Obviously
believe he cared about the person.
I'm saying he was objectively like lying to her about like trying
to make changes or trying to do anything to be who she needed.
Okay. Now I maybe maybe that's enough. That that's enough for
me not to object to. I think the I think I think the reason why
I became defensive of something that I'm not even involved in
I suppose
is just because
I didn't want it to be characterized as like this purely
No, I don't think it's like that. Sorry, if you got the if you
got the feeling that I was describing it that way no I I think
you only get that kind of stupid when there are real feelings
there sure. Okay. Okay. No, that's that's fair. Um that to to
be honest man then I guess the the only other things that I wanted
to bring up um and if you have some place else or something else
that you wanted to cover that's totally fine. Um but I did bring
up the Sherry audio recording thing. You said we just have to
let that play out. Okay, we'll let it play out. Um Kelly Jean
which is not you. I understand that you're separate people. Um
so Kelly Jean stated that she expects Steven to be incarcerated
and or broke within the next like few months and it's basically
been a year and the court case doesn't seem to be going the way
that it wants to go. Um Lav was saying that I would be Hold on.
>> Just to be clear and I I think Destiny gets confused
on this too. When I say that Destiny's not a winner in this I
think any lawyer
would go settle this. I think he said 800k if it gets dismissed.
I don't see how it would be dismissed. Maybe it'll be dismissed,
but I don't see it right now. Um personally I just if I could
see some of the legal opinion somebody saying I think it'll be
dismissed before trial then I would maybe believe that, but if
he said he said if it gets dismissed entirely
he'll have paid $800,000.
Right. I think any lawyer would have told him you can settle
this for way less than that. Like he probably could have settled
it for something like 200,000. I
mean I'm not a lawyer and I told him that and he said no on principle
and I was like all right go for it. >> So I don't think
he's like a loser in terms of the case. I think he's a loser
in terms of his pride is too high for him to make the better
decision for himself. So he's going to hurt everybody around
him. Right? It's because of his pride. And I would say that makes
him a loser.
Okay. Regardless of how the court case
Okay. Uh yeah and I think I heard a quote from you stating
uh effectively like even if the court case doesn't go in Pixie's
way losing 800 grand is still a huge black eye. So. No Well,
I don't think For me personally I'm just like you could have
settled this and had like nothing bad essentially.
Right? Yeah, I think I think from from his perspective I've heard
him say this a few times and I'm sure that you've heard it too.
The effectively like once the whatever was out the Pixie's statement
once Pixie's statement was out he was like oh that's that's as
bad as it can get. I don't know if that's true, but that that's
what he's said
Um the
Okay. So Sunday talked about taking advantage of crazy people.
We already talked about the infinite great machine. Kweiman was
saying that he should be on a list. You said that you agree with
that on principle even if it's not a legalistic thing. Lav, I'm
>> with Kweiman's opinion cuz Kweiman said the same thing.
Kweiman literally said the exact same thing the whole time. I
remember your conversations.
I just gave you what mine Me and Kweiman had the exact same position
on it. I don't see how it could have changed like one iota. There's
literally been zero evidence No, I mean if if if he still carries
that, I think my comment was just about the heat, right? Um but
I think you already caught I think you already covered that with
me by saying
uh the calculation has changed. The the the juice isn't worth
the proverbial squeeze because you're not getting the attention
and the donations and the positive community growth. You're getting
digital harassment and >> Let's say let's say we were getting
Well, I never got positive community growth. By the way, I said
from the very beginning the best way to deal with this, which
I'm not going to opt for, is to never talk about it and to just
like continue covering stuff as I used to and let people have
like their plausible deniability their little like blissfully
like ignorance and just come in, pile in, and listen to drama
and not have me have a negative opinion of Destiny. I think many
people have done that despite having a negative opinion. They
don't talk about it on stream. They try to keep it off of their
stream. And I think they've been totally fine. I think I could
have made that decision. I thought it would be a bad thing to
do.
That is by far and I maintain that from the second any of this
popped off that that would be the better financial
Okay. I know that to be true. If I'd done that, I could have
still had Dan on my stream. I would have still been making a
[__] money.
Yeah, I I I think your detractors would have said that, you know,
you backstabbed in order to milk the anti audience, but I if
you believe that earnestly, then I understand the the rationale.
I think there I think part of the reason why people always say
like EHD, right? Uh but realistically
in reference to like Nick DiOrio and um and Chud and I I I love
Chud. I again, like I'm not trying to [__] talk him
at all. I think he makes great content. Um but if you look at
their content, it's EH, right? They don't they don't do a lot
of D. So. Yeah, we all know why that is, right?
Um I mean I I think you would have a more nefarious interpretation
than me. I would say that it's because there hasn't been a lot
of developments recently within the past year, but I think you
would say that they don't want to >> Destiny a lot before
that?
Uh no. I I think I think Chud actually had a pretty clean break
with Twitch and YouTube politics and I think he said that that
was a conscious choice.
Was it Twitch and YouTube politics that he wanted to clean break
with?
Um I think that he thought that it was overly dominated by Steven
and therefore the best um the the best way out was just to not
uh fall into the trap of constantly being in the Destiny orbit.
Yeah, that's I again.
Yeah, exactly. It was to get away from Destiny, right? Like and
the the people >> Um yeah, but but I I don't know if that's
like a but really over
There could be like more personal but as an outsider
as an outsider I still have no idea what's true there.
Uh the the the spicy chat Kiwi Farms cross-pollination thing
do I'm just telling you as an outsider as an outsider I still
have no idea what's true there. There was a whole thing where
you had like a massive problem with with spicy chat before that,
right?
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, but but the but the argument I'm trying to
I'm trying to say
earnestly. I'm trying to say this earnestly. As somebody who
is stuck between many communities, right? It is hard to not look
at the way that um people conduct themselves in drama discords
and not believe that there is strong cross-pollination into more
online communities.
Right? It seems like the only thing that they're they're reeled
in by
All the time you have to always carry something along there,
compared to Destiny's community or compared to the communities
that are making this allegation, right?
So, you you can't make this allegation without analyzing how
much cross-pollination there is with your community and some
of the more extreme online communities. And I do not believe
that there's a significantly larger cross-pollination between
my community and any more extreme online community than there
is with DGG and any more extreme online community, right? So,
it we're comparing against a standard. We're trying to figure
out where we measure up to that standard, right? But we always
leave that leave that out. Oh, is there any cross-pollination?
Well, sure, but like obviously Destiny's allowed Kiwi Farms links
in his chat for since forever. His his thread has been a topic
of conversation in his chat since forever,
Like there's a ton of cross-pollination. The idea that oh, the
bar is zero cross-pollination. No, that's not a reasonable reasonable
bar for anybody. >> And and can I ask though because I
think I could use my community even though it's small as an example.
Um so, for instance with um with Pisco's community, I have to
assume because I have engaged with some of Pisco's content uh
that it is uh sure, there might be some like drama stuff. There
might be some old
uh old uh Destiny hangovers. There might be some orbiter stuff.
Blah-blah-blah-blah-blah. But I have to assume that there's also
a large portion of the community that is almost there I don't
want to say exclusively,
but is there largely
for Pisco's uh political and legalistic analysis because it's
so much of his content, right? And then same way with my community,
um I would say that I do cover dramatic topics, but I would also
say that I I don't [clears throat] touch the proverbial poo.
I'm not in a specific beef
with any creator.
And so as a result, we might tangentially talk about drama, but
we're not in like a digital war with any other community. And
I feel like
I feel like you got like Kweiman and DGG and you, I feel like
you guys have been engaged in a digital war for the better part
of a year. Again, that's I'm sort of getting that's sort of getting
super one-sided in terms of the tactics, right? So, again, I'll
say timeline-wise, Destiny brought out this whole this whole
example this narrative that he used, right? Well, these guys
are involved in like swating and doxing. These guys dox people,
right? He did that in February of 2025,
almost a year
No examples of that. No proof given, right? Then he started doxing
people in March of 2025,
right?
No proof. No examples of any of the conduct he alleged.
5-6 months later, there's proof of some conduct that happened
maybe 2 months before that. I'm I'm curious by what moral standard
do they judge even the cyber stuff, which would be the only version
of touching the poo I'm aware of, okay?
When they've literally made it clear and they have gone and started
doxing people for months at that point. Yeah, and and this is
why it's been
Sorry. Uh part part of this conversation has been revelatory
where I'm hoping what what I said from the beginning was that
um Steven has done wrong things and he should suffer whatever
legal punishments are ascribed to him by the state. Um and then
ultimately, I think we should all move on. This might be self-serving
to say, but I think it's also true. You understand that hearing
that like oh, well, Kweiman and Jstark have decided that the
juice isn't worth the squeeze. They're not going to cover Destiny
anymore um and as result, we might see a correlated drawdown
in the digital war. That's actually good news clear for a lot
of people. I've not been covering him for like weeks now despite
him consistently pulling up like screenshots in my Discord, trying
to dox people. I like barely cover it. I I could even try and
it's like not worth it. Um it's especially not worth it given
how like the ranged he is, but I again, I just don't understand.
Like you could say oh, it's because you're losing now. It's like
no, it's literally because you are threatening people like my
friends. You are your former friends, my friends. Like when he
threatens to dox dox Wicked
like I don't understand under what what is the logic there? How
is he possibly supporting that? How are like not so erudite was
a close friend of Wicked Supreme's. How in the is she still around
when Destiny's threatening to dox him with no reason for it?
Is um yeah, and I mean like I Wicked and I, we we got a little
bit of a history. Um friendly and not friendly. Um but I guess
my
>> What What do you think is the most If you were to try
not to You don't need to steelman Steven's position. Let Let
me ask this question though. Um what do you think is the most
like unhinged or hateful thing that Wicked Supreme has either
said or done
in the past like year?
So, all I can say is when Destiny first got mad at Supreme, it
was he made a joke about how he used to like Louis CK and Bill
Cosby and then he like Destiny and he's like am I the one doing
it? Destiny saw that joke and he freaked out and said Wicked
Supreme actually like groomed Pixie as her boss and tried to
[__] her and they had a whole fallout,
Which multiple people, Sam Seder, Mel Erudite, both came out
on Twitter and said that's an obvious lie. He's just making that
up, right? But you guys continuously explain this away, which
is the frustrating thing for me cuz it's like
like I was probably not closer to Supreme than any of you guys,
but now I I feel like he's probably thinking like well, this
guy's the only person who is willing to call out the harassment
and say like this is a part of a bigger issue when it clearly
is.
Well, I don't like 8 months and Supreme is now under threat of
being doxed by Destiny. And again, I haven't seen, you know,
I haven't seen Erudite come out publicly and say hey, this person's
threatening to to dox my friend. That's really [__]
up. I haven't seen you do that. Although I I again, I haven't
seen you do that. Maybe you have done that. Um No, I I I No,
I would say that I've been about as as neutral as one can be
under the circumstance and you guys might ascribe like moral
cowardice to that position.
Um but we we can talk about that in a Let's finish this up. >> to
be clear, I ascribe moral cowardice to not asking for the proof
that he had to engage in the doxing campaign in the first place.
All of you people are cowards for not demanding proof and then
when he refused to give proof, you say, "K, [__]
off until you give me proof of it." No, the Okay, so so I've
asked for proof and what I received from the community, not from
Steven himself, actually from somebody else in the community,
was I received that I think it was Blahv. I I could double-check
the DMs and see if it was Blahv. Um but Blahv was basically like
in spicy chat under a obvious Blahv PFP. Then uh he did get banned
after doxing someone in the community.
And then uh he came back under an alter a PFP um that was still
obviously him. And then I don't know when he got banned after
that, but the the screenshots that I was shown were like
April of 25.
And so since then we've had like a whole year, right? So so when
you say there's when Steven says
that there's this like active cross-pollination
and harassment campaign, well, the most recent evidence of cross-pollination
was April of 25, at least from what I >> You You understand
that I just So So you you just told me you got no proof and then
told me a story about how you were given something. You You would
admit that's not proof of anything, right? Yeah, but I mean I
I would say that that's evidence of the Keemstar >> Did
Destiny dox Chud Logic?
Did Destiny dox Chud Logic? Did Destiny dox Chud Logic? >> think
so.
Okay. Uh where am I I haven't been in spicy chat for like 6 months.
Oh, sorry. I was in there for like 2 weeks ago for like a second.
But other than that, I haven't been in spicy chat for like 6
months. I literally haven't been in the server. So I Where Where
am I connected to that? Why did you just say when I asked for
proof of my community being connected? Why did I just get that?
And by the way, can we just Can we just acknowledge as well that
that is obviously not a bar by which you could dox somebody?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I'm just I'm I'm basically telling you
that I asked for evidence from the DGG community and that's the
strongest evidence that I got in the past year. So you You're
saying that that's weak evidence and >> be misleading for
you to say you had no no effective or convincing evidence of
this whatsoever? Do you think that would be misleading? >> but
let me tell you what feels dishonest about what you're telling
me right now, >> No, no, no. Answer that question first
and then explain to me why it feels dishonest. Just yes or no.
Okay. Sorry, what what's the what's the direct >> Have
you been Have you been given convincing evidence that would lead
you to believe that you could hold me or Qman responsible for
doxing? Have you been given any convincing evidence of this?
Okay. Thank you. Now, go ahead and explain why you think that's
Now, you're going to say that it's difficult to
Uh yeah. Okay. And and and it's difficult to prove what do we
do? Hold on. Let me Let me Hold on. I I answered your question
and I also want an opportunity to >> Yeah, I'm I don't
want to talk over you. Go ahead.
So the the difficulty to prove, you you kind of say it flippantly.
uh we all know how direct messages work. We We all know that
we can't I communicate with people with the expectation that
anything that I say can
and ultimately might be screenshotted and posted to Twitter.
That That's That's how I behave on the internet. However, I know
it's entirely possible for people to have closed group DMs, for
people to have private DMs, for people to make alts, for people
to make PFPs. So when you when you ask like, "Hey, do you have
any direct evidence of anybody in my community or me or Qman
um participating in a digital harassment campaign?" And the answer
is no, then you're like, "Well, then obviously it's not happening."
But that's not really the same thing, is it? I'm actually saying
given that you don't have evidence, actually
I mean
Well, I would say what evidence is there against Supreme or Esports
Batman too, >> There There isn't. >> Like I I've
already said there isn't.
So you then the allegation would be in DMs. I would say, "What
do you think you're allowed to do when you can't prove something
but you're fairly certain it's true?" Do you think there's like
a moderating force there that you shouldn't go to the levels
of like, "Oh, I'm going to go eye for an eye over something I
can't prove actually
No. Um and I've actually had a very specific conversation about
this uh with
So the uh we we we talked about levels of like reciprocal violence,
tit for tat, eye for eye, uh turning the other cheek, and barbarian
reciprocal violence. And I think that consistently
Qman and your and Doobie and probably Wicked Supreme if he ever
actually I haven't seen him make content recently. Um but if
they were ever to address this in content form, I think that
the the crux of your criticism is and I've I've told Steven this
is that I think I told him this on stream, by the way. Um is
that he's saying that he's engaged in eye for an eye or tit for
tat, but when you actually look at the behavior, it's like scorched
earth barbarian retributive violence. And so he has these bad
things that are being done to him, but he's like doing the equivalent
of like uh the English kings from Braveheart and you know, like
setting the villages on fire.
Yep. And I would say that I probably would have said that to
his face. I said that on stream. Well, you You said that to his
face, but then you're going to keep doing content with him, which
is fine. But then when he goes and lies about Pisco and uses
the same narratives against Pisco, I think probably you guys
I'm I'm hoping at some point, right?
I think I push back against that more.
>> Because because Pisco, in my opinion, Pisco's um quote-unquote
bad faith, his aggression,
in my opinion,
um is so clearly not this like uh angry, vindictive,
personal [__] I think the man, like, no offense,
Pisco, but I think he legitimately has like a form of autism.
And if you don't agree with him, he almost views that as like
I don't want to say like an insult, um but he's quite passionate
about people disagreeing with him. And so he's been Pisco has
actually, I would say, um I don't know if you saw him say that
he engaged in aftercare with Hutch. Um the joke in my community
is that Pisco is effectively a sadomasochistic
debater. No, I I can tell you I've given my opinion on Pisco.
Pisco gets annoyed because he puts far more time and effort into
coming up with his opinions than other people. And then these
people come and they they say things that they haven't thought
through. He gets very frustrated when people literally haven't
thought through stuff. Like when Hutch goes into a conversation
with Pisco and says, "I haven't thought about what the percentage
is that Denims is responsible for CPS." But he's also advocating
for it being totally cool to ruin Denims' life because of the
CPS call. Like that is a person who you shouldn't take seriously.
That is a person who's a complete [__] [__]
who shouldn't be taken seriously by anybody. And so Pisco's naturally
upset because he's so nice. What the Yeah, but I think unfortunately
for Hutch
Unfortunately for Hutch, wait. If I said that you should go and
and sue Counter Points, destroy Counter Points' life, I don't
care how you do it, destroy his life. And then you said, "Wait,
why are you doing that?" I'm like, "Well, you know, I haven't
really thought about that much." I would be a I'd be a complete
joke, right? But But is is thought is thoughtlessness a crime
particularly in Twitch and YouTube politics and are we thinking
about thinking about it every single day and holding our ideas
every single day? When When Pisco is mean to you, that is why.
Is because you were being thoughtless in a place where he has
been very thoughtful and you are wasting his time by by engaging
your thoughtlessness in his presence. I'm telling you that is
why he's mad at you. That's why he's mad at you. I can see
You You can say that in general, but I have I have had Pisco
go off
on things that were actually quite tepid, but we disagreed on.
And he got I think I covered some stuff like that recently and
I I probably said Pisco's going too hard on you at one
Well, but but I do think he's coming to terms with the fact that
he was gaslit super hard over some stuff recently and trying
to figure out how to handle that better going forward, so. Well,
and I I think but I but this has been our
Pisco and I have been internet debate friends for probably 3
to 5 years now. So So So that that's where I don't I don't take
his autism as like actually like overt hatred or hostility. I
take it as Pisco gets passionate at sometimes and um you know,
just give it a day, he'll cool off, he'll
organize his thoughts, I'll try to articulate my thoughts better,
and then we'll meet somewhere in the middle and that's typically
how we manage our relationship. So So yeah, so um basically I
think Steven I think you I think you dislike or hate Steven.
Okay.
I think you do. I think when you think of Steven, you have an
emotional reaction, it's very negative, you don't like him, you
think he's a bad person, you want him to be punished for his
And I think Qman is the same way. I mean, that's sort of faded
quite a bit. I mean, I don't like him, sure, but this faded a
bit. It's not like um a visceral thing where I like have to go
off hard about it. I could potentially if there's like a lot
of lies happening. Um and again, I just think I personally just
I find it again I I stopped finding Destiny interesting sometime
like sometime ago. What I find interesting now is how long it
will take, like how long the rest of the orbiters will continue
to play like their Europe with like, you know, doing appeasement.
I I just think it's very funny that you guys like did this through
the whole thing with me and Queenman. We were both pointing out
there's no evidence for this. It's crazy that you're doing this.
And now Pisco's been roped in and it's just going to continue
to happen with anybody who criticizes him, anybody who's against
him in any way. He'll continue to like make these things up and
and push you guys around because
I I think you guys take it because there's a monetary incentive
to do so. And I just I find that very funny that like your old
friends are being lied about explicitly. You can identify that
they're being lied about. You can identify that they're being
threatened. And you guys are just going You're kind of like closing
your eyes and going like, "Ah, it's not happening. It's not happening.
It's not happening." Uh I don't I I don't think that's true at
>> You least of all, but still there's like a group of
you guys who are doing it. It's quite funny to me. >> Okay.
The
Uh I appreciate that moderate concession. Um I I think one of
my
is there is a video um because because I get accused of sweeping
all the time. And I think I actually quite succinctly
if you go back through my content, I'll admit it's more tactful
than your guys' content, absolutely. But if you go back into
the CounterPoints Politics channel and you check out >> um
the Mr. Girl summary,
uh the Mr. Girl report summary, if you check out the
uh the 2025
Destiny drama uh essay, if you check out a conversation that
actually like it starts
it it ends with a conversation with Rittenhouse, but the beginning
of it is
something. I I I could look it up. I could find it. The The thumbnail
is me with a screenshot that says like mercy, atonement, forgiveness,
all that right? Yeah, I watched I watched a decent amount of
your Game of Thrones layout.
Uh well, in the in the Game of Thrones one, right? That The Game
of Thrones one is probably the newest iteration of this of this
content. But but I feel like I uh even if you guys dislike how
friendly I am with Steven, um I still feel like I describe reality
pretty accurately.
And when when I ask people like what what Number one, what am
I omitting? Number two, what sin of commission am I creating?
Often times I don't get a strong answer.
Um what sin of commission? I would say by still validating it,
by still like appearing on stream and being in that community
and not like generally disavowing. I do think that you do validate
a little bit. I think the inability to defend your friends more
more like explicitly.
I know that Supreme got DMs from people being like, "Hey, what's
going on here?"
I don't understand why that went through DMs. I don't understand
why that wasn't a public thing. I think anybody who DMed Supreme
to be like, "Hey, what's going on here?" I think you are a cowardly
loser. Would you disagree with that? That if people just DMed
Supreme about this, they didn't just go, "Hey, wait, why Destiny,
why are you doing this?" And then when he couldn't give any evidence
of why he was doing it, for them not to go, "Hey, this guy's
like doxing my friend." I think that's like cowardly. I think
that's openly cowardly.
I think it's sad. Sorry, you're muted. You're muted on Discord.
Yeah. >> my apologies. The I I think it does get weird
though. Can I want to bring up an example and I want to rope
uh Lycan and Erin and Supreme in uh the because I I think these
are all examples, okay? Why do you want to rope Can I just ask
first why you want to rope Lycan and and Erin in? Because I think
they explicitly tried to avoid it. >> I would consider
them like I wouldn't consider them friends, but I would definitely
consider them like uh definitely like friendly internet associates,
I suppose. Okay, sorry. Yeah, go ahead. Yeah, so so what um in
reference to Lycan, my my entire interactions with that man have
been We've been on a couple of panels and we've thrown elbows
a couple of times together. Then I went down to Miami two or
three times and we got beers, I think twice.
And then uh he I think was with Erin at the time. And so we hung
out with Erin. And then Erin, despite calling me like a a mall
cop mall cop piece of [__] dumb ass who doesn't know
[__] about law enforcement and an arsonist and me
calling her the C-slur cuz I that was actually like a I think
that was our first conversation. It might have been our second
conversation. Um but it was a very spicy conversation by the
way, even on Twitch.
What's that?
You can say those words even on Twitch.
Well, I I won't say it just because it's rude, fine. But but
it's the it's the female misogynist C-slur. Um >> Yeah,
I literally said >> And so I I called her that and that
was our first interaction and then our second interaction was
kind of like chilling in a parking lot, right? And like hanging
out with Lycan and and doing some shopping before we went and
did some PV work. And that's like the extent of our friendship.
And like once every 6 months I'll, you know, Lycan will DM me
and he'll be like, "Hey, how's it going?" And and I'll be like,
"It's good. How are you?" Blah blah blah blah blah. But that's
the extent of our relationship. And I would say with Wicked Supreme,
it was the same thing. He dogpiled me in that same conversation.
Then we met at a PV event. >> to be fair, you invoked him
without
without his support. I think he kind of had to turn against you
there when you were invoking like his experience.
In a way he disagreed with it. >> I still stand by everything
I said in that conversation and I think I made a video essay
about that one as well.
I I think I invoked his military service because he said he worked
in intel.
So, anyways, we we don't have to relitigate that debate. But
but the point is like three interactions over the course of two
years, one of them incredibly hostile in a debate and two of
them friendly in person. Okay. >> Yeah, friendly. So you're
you're not that close to
>> What's that? You're not that close to Supreme. You don't
feel like it's your job to say that that's not Well, not just
that, but even even Lycan and Erin. If If I I don't think they
hang out with Steven half as much as they used to and I have
no idea why.
So so am I supposed to go like investigate? Am I supposed to
poke around? Am I supposed to say, "Hey, why why are you guys
not as close to friends as you used to be?" Um you know, like
like what what is my responsibility
um to these people who I've met, you know, two or three times
and we're largely positive. Even Pixie, dude. I have no ill will
towards Pixie. >> For sure. I don't think Destiny's like
threatening to publicly to like dox Erin or Lycan. So like I
don't think you have the same. So like there I'm like you don't
have to go figure out why they don't hang out. I It's not that
big a deal. Right. But but I'm but I'm just saying like um with
with Pixie,
we might have been on a panel a couple of times together and
we hung out during PV events and she was incredibly nice and
so was LonerBox.
And if they if LonerBox and her wanted to get beers or whatever,
I'd be like, "Yeah, let's go get beers." But once again, it's
like what is my
What it What is my loyalty? What what what is my um What [snorts]
is my responsibility? Uh I don't know. I I just think that
I So if I had to just be like honest about it, I think you're
entirely financially motivated to not say anything. And I have
a hard time throwing too much like [__] at people
for this cuz I think that's how I was originally. Um although
I was willing to just say I think it's entirely financial motivation
at the time. Um like financially motivated to continue to remain
ignorant on Steven's like downside or his flaws, the bad things
he's done, but to look into the bad things like I've done or
Queenman's done. Like I I think that's the general bend is you
are financially incentivized to continue to go in that direction.
So I'm probably going to have a hard time convincing you of like
anything super negative. I I don't think your analysis of the
situation in terms of Destiny being like one-sided and [__]
>> ago. What lies of commission or omission have I engaged
in? What part of Steven's bad behavior have I not described in
that video? >> No lies, but you just identified two patterns
that you thought were curious and you didn't look any deeper
on them.
What patterns? Be specific.
Uh that he isn't talking to Lycan or Shraederate anymore.
Uh well, well, hold hold on. What What I'm asking you for is
that uh we we both know and I think everybody in chat knows so
and if somebody watches this and reacts to it, I think they'll
know as well that Steven was engaged with four or five women
all at the same time in 2022, which led to his personal life
imploding. And specifically, when it came to several of those
women who are the most important in his life, um he lied to them
about the nature of his relationship with other women and as
a result. So we we have a lie, right? A lie of commission that
Steven has committed. Uh but we knew that. Are you talking about
like him What's What's the lie there? Uh I I would in my opinion,
and again, I know this is overly personal, um but I feel like
he was misrepresenting the seriousness of his relationship with
Lauren in order to continue it uh because if he actually told
Melina how serious the relationship was, Melina would have vetoed
it.
Oh, sure.
Right. Okay. >> So so we've known that and I think that's
To be clear. Okay? Yeah. Um and and so and you got you have brought
up times where you think that he's committing lies of commission.
Uh I think the main ones that you cite are the fact that he has
totally weak evidence in reference to the Kiwi Farms J Star Queenman
community cross-pollination and yet he's using it as a pretext
for a scorched earth digital war.
So on that point, just real quick before you continue. Actually,
you should probably finish first, but I do want to come back
to that point cuz I think it's not just weak evidence. I think
the thing that he said was happening, he knows for a fact he's
lying about. As in, it's not even just him being like um angry
or or emotional. He knows for a fact that he is lying.
That that you and Queenman are not involved in the digital harassment
campaign of him or his wife. >> campaign from like Kiwi
Farms where he says he's being doxxed and swatted by Kiwi Farms
which he criticized Keffals for without evidence but I'm sure
go
that that obviously came from other places and he attributed
to me and Queenman to try to get us to shut up to try to threaten
us. Then when we didn't shut up he just carried through with
it without any evidence but like basically knowing that none
of his friends had been doxxed since he'd started making threats
since the stuff had come out. None of his friends had been doxxed.
Um Erudite said she'd been swatted. I think the swatting happened
way before um any of the Destiny leaks came out. Um because Erudite
has DMs with me where she asked me to come on Anything Else and
she says I say no the Kiwi Farms is getting crazy, right? This
is in maybe October or November of 2024.
Yeah, 2024. And I say no the Kiwi Farms is getting crazy. I'm
not going I'm not showing my face. I'm not trying to get doxxed
right now. And she said yeah we've been like the police have
been called a couple times on us and stuff. So and and she went
on Twitter and tried to imply that Queenman and I had something
to do with that. And it's like you know for a fact that I told
you that this was something I was concerned about. I obviously
disavowed it. I obviously wasn't involved. I obviously thought
I was a target.
And so there's no way you could possibly blame me for the [__]
that happened before any of the leaks happened and he started
doxxing people before anyone else had been doxxed or harassed
as far as I know that wasn't already.
Right? Like Hutch got doxxed in September of 2024 and then Destiny
tried to blame us for it in like May of 2025.
Yeah, there would be a
in in order to make heads or tails of this I would have to do
like an entire like digital forensics
investigation and I'm I'm just I'm not there. Um I think I think
I'm okay like like if your if your perspective and by the way
like if your perspective is that he's lying about it so he can
conduct digital warfare
against his detractors
I can just accept that because I think I've told him
to his face on stream on something else or whatever. I said hey
why why does
deserve this level of mistreatment? What evidence do you have
that these people are engaged specifically the people uh you
Queenman and Doobie and he basically said they know.
They know. They know what they're doing. That was his That was
his response.
>> What is your opinion then on Hasan [__]
and his monetization on Twitch given his violation of the TOS?
Do you think he should be deplatformed from Twitch given his
violations of the TOS? Uh which ones? I don't know. I assume
you'd have a good understanding of them. Do you think broadly
Hasan [__] should not be
Supports terrorism, violations of the
I'm I'm actually of split minds on this,
On on one hand I think Hasan [__] should suffer.
I think that you know sweeping for authoritarianism trying to
you know basically openly saying on some podcast that he's a
sock dem in the streets but he's a tankie in the sheets and he's
creating like a socialist sales funnel. Yeah, you think he should
be punished but you just don't know how.
Yeah and and I and I don't know if deplatforming him or demonetizing
him achieves what I want to achieve because having him in the
zeitgeist
kind of makes him an ideological sparring partner
that is
it's worth it to the American political zeitgeist to have these
conversations.
So then I would follow up with given Destiny has the the reason
I asked was I was going to say given that Destiny has failed
to produce evidence. I if if what I'm alleging is true that he
that nobody was doxxed or harassed in that in like that kind
of way that wasn't already happening, right? Like no I as far
as I know nobody was ba basically nobody was doxxed. If somebody
was doxxed it's like somebody who is
I don't even know how to explain it. It's like something I might
have missed but I've I've gone through this. I don't think anybody
was essentially doxxed maybe one person. I think I think Tom
Foolery got threatened at some point in February or something.
Yeah, hold on. So I know of
uh because I think these ones are less serious I'll say them
by name and then there's two more that I know >> no sorry.
I'm saying it happened either before
Sorry
obviously obviously I can't be blamed for Elder Druzi, right?
I'm talking about what I could be blamed for for him to go for
a doxxing campaign against my community. So nobody was doxxed
from the time where I could even remotely perceptibly be considered
against until he had doxxed multiple people, right? Eventually
I think there's a WillyMac doxx that gets dropped. Not I don't
believe that came from my community. In fact I'm almost positive
that came from Bad Empanada stuff. Like I would lean that way
way harder that Willy was doing video essays in Bad Empanada
and that's probably what happened. I don't know for sure though.
Like and I that that's just my leaning. You never punish somebody
for that cuz it's my leaning, okay? Okay but that's my leaning.
>> do you see the Game of Thrones drawing
And and and what I mean by this is we when when I drew the Game
>> I
I understand if you're just going to say well I know he's lying
about you explicitly and engaging in like crazy tactics explicitly
and I'm still going to be friends with them. You're just going
to tell me you're going to be friends with people like that then
it's like really rough for me to
No, that's fine. You you don't you don't have to
you don't have to like it or whatever but but I want to make
this point because I think I think it's coherent. So when I was
drawing and I invite people to check out that Game of Thrones
drawing cuz I actually think it's really
I drew J Stalk's rebellion which which was effectively the it
was the war of the roses but it was the war of the rose and it
was effectively like this drama that's kicked off for the past
year and a half involving a bunch of detractors against you know
the mad king Destiny. I think it's actually really funny. And
I I do think there's I do think there's just a language thing
here I want to point out. You say detractors.
I was this guy's like biggest supporter.
He's the person who failed, right? He's the person who failed
to live up to his >> times people's biggest detractors
are the people who loved them the most.
Sure, you could say that. I just I supported this guy. I thought
he was trying to do something good. It was get being given evidence
that he is not really trying to do anything good. He's aggrandizing
himself.
>> even if you think he's a bad person or even if he has
vices.
He has to engage in the in all kinds of insane lying to try to
do this, right? Can I ask you just as an example?
Yeah. The implied consent lie. The obvious implied consent lie.
We now have evidence via this transcript via the court case in
general that that's obviously false, right?
Well, actually can we argue this for a second? So
Ooh, it's going to get really misogynous really quick. Should
we go down this line? Uh yeah.
Okay. Um I was told coming up because I'm old as hell. I'm almost
40. That effectively whenever you send any text message, any
video, any pictures
via the internet you should effectively expect that to be public.
And so when I see a half dozen or a dozen people
Nobody thinks that. Nobody thinks that cuz that's not how any
of the laws work. That's not how any of the laws work. So clearly
that's not where where our morality is centered around, right?
Is whether or not like you could reasonably expect this? Like
this is just the the reality thing. You're arguing like well
is should you really hold somebody responsible for they're sitting
in a alley waiting for a victim? Right? And I think that this
perspective >> No no no you just didn't listen to what
I said cuz I just laid the whole thing out for you really really
simply.
You're basically arguing that we shouldn't punish or we shouldn't
consider somebody like a a bad person for sitting in a alley
waiting for a victim that they It's like yeah I understand that
the person could maybe expect it but
Okay, go ahead. No, I just I just think your analogy is bad.
What is What is your reasoning for bringing up that you could
expect somebody to share
And by the way that's not the argument he made so I'm not going
to give him credence for that argument. Just to be clear he's
not arguing that by sending it you're consenting. Yeah, let me
let me go a little bit further and and this is why I was saying
should we even go down this line of
When I see
Stacia, Melina
Lauren I don't think sent any videos or pictures, right? She
just sent intimate DMs.
Rose Uh what what Abby as well.
What's that?
Abby as well.
Um and I'm I'm not familiar with Abby but let's just say that
that's the thing. It's like on the record that all of these people
had their nudes leaked by this guy. Two other people had them
like transmitted without their consent. So just on the record.
I don't think anybody denies any of this stuff. So so when we're
when we're talking about half a dozen people
and some of those people for instance
Pixie and Melina
are talking about shooting content with other people
and then sharing it online with other
Uh yeah my you don't have to agree with this morally but my sympathy
plummets into the [__] ground. You're you're trying
to attach Melina and Pixie together but that's just not the case,
right? So this is what Destiny does to like lie about this. Pixie
had one other partner it was her boyfriend who she had videos
with that she shared with Destiny.
Yeah, that's
crazy to a normal person.
It's you you you understand?
For most normal people it's crazy to video yourself having sex
with one partner and then sharing it with the consent of both
partners to another partner online. >> You're applying
your lens in a way that Destiny doesn't even represent his own
lens. So you're trying to use your lens to explain this. That's
not how Destiny thinks about it, right?
Yeah, but that's also because Destiny is insane in reference
to some matters. Okay, you understand that you're just using
insane here to totally sweep away the actual conversation and
treating people like adults. Like they had they had agreements,
they had understandings that would be like like when when Destiny
says that he had a conversation where he said that they were
They're represented in the court documents where Destiny said
that I I or sorry, maybe in his response. I forget where he said
it precisely. But he was like, "I told Pixie that Melina had
access to all my stuff and that she could very easily see the
video." That is his fundamental argument for saying there was
implied consent there.
So, we know that, right? >> of course that doesn't give
you I heard you say this and I agree with you when you say this.
Because of that, that does not mean that you have unlimited license
to take said content and share it with everyone in perpetuity.
I think that's almost a direct quote from you. And I agree with
that. >> That is something I would say, but that is explicitly
why well he when he was building this implied consent argument,
he lied to everybody, Pixie included,
how long he'd known Rose, what his relationship with Rose was.
How long do you think he knew Rose before he sent those videos?
I think we're
honestly, man, we can keep going if you want. But
I'm basically just going to say a bunch of like vile misogynist
stuff that you're probably not going to >> Yeah, but but
hold on. But if Destiny can say that same vile misogynist stuff
and say that he lied when he went in the red pill arc, he didn't
believe any of it, he was just lying to sleep with as many women
as as he could because he's a degenerate lying loser. If he wants
to do that, he can do that. But I I'm going to hold him to the
standard he set out and I don't think that's unreasonable to
Do you think that's unreasonable to do? This is an important
question, though. And I I think you might have already answered
it in your behavior.
So, let let let's go down this line of argumentation.
So, Steven from your perspective and from the perspective of
a lot of his critics has been found to be hypocritical in reference
to some matters because he said on Red Pill Podcast, I'm presuming
I'm making a presumption here based off of the clips that were
presented in video essays, that like consent is number one and
making sure that your partner is comfortable and making sure
that everything you're doing is in line with what the other person
wants and this that the other. That's like some of the most critical
>> women like they deserve autonomy and respect and are
like actually people you should consider. Like right? Like treating
them like normal human beings that they shouldn't lie to them,
you should just lie to them because that's totally meaningless
empty
Right? Stuff like that. Yeah, yeah. Sure, whereas I I think my
perspective is more like um it's more paternalistic, I suppose.
I guess is the nicest way to put it. And I would say as people
are pointing out, Bob 7 Bob 7's career by Destiny's own urging
was destroyed, right? He said for sharing these videos these
these nudes these images and content without their consent, he
should have his this should be career ending. So, it was Destiny's
position that doing this kind of thing should be career ending.
Okay. So, let's
So, so let's go to the the consequences imposed because basically
over the past year, year and a half, um Steven has had a ton
of consequences imposed and I actually think that the um the
crux of the conversation and argument that we've been having
is what does Steven deserve, I suppose.
so, what I would say is losing 90% of your orbit, 95% of your
orbit, a lot of your digital friends coming out and saying that
they will no longer associate with you, losing a lot of professional
relationships as a result, and then losing eight I think you
said $800,000
to a civil case that he might still lose, maybe he'll win, maybe
he'll lose, who knows. But I think that I've heard some people
estimate his savings and retirement fund We will have to go into
this. Sorry, what's that? Well, sorry, we will have to go into
I've literally never once So, other than at the very beginning
within like the first week, maybe, I don't think I've ever suggested
that he would win the case against Pixie outside of I believe
there's more evidence out there and if they can find it, then
they'll win. But like outside of that, um I think the the strongest
thing I said is he clearly violates every element of Cardi with
regards to the Pixie stuff
except for the date. The he's the violation is before the law
was passed and therefore he can't sue under it, right? So, Okay,
but then uh uh the finalization >> somebody says somebody
says I misspoke and said
um I've never said that he would lose, I guess. Um basically
my position was that it's difficult to prove that they're going
to need more evidence, that I don't see the evidence there to
like prove this, but if they have what they said, then I think
this would be a slam dunk. But I think they can prove that. >> like
80 80% of my criticism was about like energy and vibes.
Uh and when I started taking notes, I told you I was taking notes
before we had this conversation, I realized that the the most
of the specific quotes that I remembered were Present Sunday,
Kelly Jean,
Aquaman,
Lav, and Mr. Girl. And I realized that I actually didn't have
specific quotes from you. I only had your associations with these
And so, I actually rolling into this conversation, you could
have told me like, "Oh yeah, I think he's a bad guy, but I never
said that he was ever going to be criminally or civilly accountable."
And that could have been perfectly true and I would have not
known the difference.
Sure. So, I did say that I think he will be criminally accountable.
>> What What I'm asking you on principle
is considering the consequences that have been imposed on Steven
over the past year and a half,
When is it enough? When has karmic
justice been served?
Um I mean, if he'd been contrite, it would have been served a
long time ago. There's been no contrition. He's continued to
attack my community, me specifically, right since there are like
new things that have been added onto the
Obviously, right?
Continues to attack Pisko in like a totally disingenuous way.
Um another thing that goes onto the pile. Like as soon as he
like stops lying to protect himself, um we can start going like,
"Well, I guess we're done here. I guess we're done covering this."
Right? But as long as he's going to lie openly in a way that
I can laugh about and cover, then I like I don't see it's not
really about what he deserves, right? I can't I can't execute
any punishment on him. Me covering him is not punishment on him.
Me covering when he lies about stuff is not punishment on him,
right? So, I I'm not trying to like
enforce punishment on him. I'm pointing out that he's lying about
things and then that he's running like a psychotic Russian campaign.
Okay. Is he Is that Is that entirely true? The The reason why
I'm asking is because
it it does feel I mean, it's almost certainly not entirely true,
but go ahead. Well, well, the the reason why I'm asking is because
it's like I feel like I've had a a pretty like sober
relationship with this. As much as I've talked about it, as much
as I've covered it, obviously because people love drama and they
love some and they love blood. Um as much as I've covered it,
I feel like I've been pretty sober the entire
and I feel like my initial reaction of
people are being hyperbolic about the legalistic consequences
that Steven's going to suffer based off of currently available
information. I think I said that multiple times. Uh based off
of currently available information. And then not just that, these
things are bad, but I don't think that he's like an irredeemably
evil
Uh to some degree I still believe that or and I'm still acting
in that way. And so, like for me, I feel like I've had like a
pretty like sober insane response to it, whereas I feel like
a lot of people have dedicated a ton of time and energy to trying
to hate this man to
uh yeah, like like like um
I don't [snorts] know. I I you might be personally sated to the
point that you feel like you said what you needed to say, the
juice isn't worth the squeeze, the war is kind of over on your
end.
>> or do you think he was participating back? Do you think
it was like mostly No, I think 100%. Sorry, I didn't mean to
imply in any way whatsoever that he wasn't engaged in this war.
He's 100% engaged in this war. I think I've I think I've told
him repeatedly it's like, "I don't even know why you engage in
the war because it feels like if you stopped engaging, half of
these people would disappear." I I think I think the war gives
fuel to the fire of the
Well, I think but here's the thing is I literally will stop covering
this guy for like weeks at a time and he will consistently be
going over my Discord over and over and over again, right?
Like he is consistently obsessed with my Discord, the people
in it. But but is it is that not because because you're you're
saying that it's like nefarious or bad or whatever, but it is
you think that's not rooted in him earnestly believing in like
the cross-pollination theory? I think it's rooted in he can't
handle people having negative opinions of him and he wants to
make it like completely untenable to have a negative opinion
of him. What he What his ultimate position is is people expressing
their like negative opinions of me for any persistent amount
of time is something I'm going to dox people over.
But see, that doesn't feel entirely true because obviously he
did that like crazy Texas tweet and the Corey Comperatore tweet
and
he he's thrived on negative attention for years. Uh sure. Maybe
people who have some close of with them When he feels betrayed
that when he feels betrayed maybe he feels betrayed. >> betrayal
might be like a bigger motivator than negativity.
Yeah, sure. Okay. That he feels like he helped people and then
if they do something bad to him after he helped them, he's going
to lie about them for the rest of time. He's going to lie about
them, go after them in any way he can.
Um if he but in basically that is he's trying to do the calculus
of like what can I do to this person that I can get away with.
So with Ana Var it was like >> Well, you know that this
is why I kind of wish >> doxing. With Hassan it's threatening
like oh I'm going to cover you and I'm like be really annoying
to you all the time. Right? You you know you know this is actually
why there's like a a part of me that wish Lauren Southern had
That uh Lauren had actually like uh converted him into a Christian
and he started reading >> but she couldn't have succeeded
because he was in the DMs, right? That he was like he was representing
that. Well, I think we see that she wasn't succeeding. That none
of that was truly sincere, >> I don't know, man. May- maybe
I'm just carrying a light for a a flicker in the darkness, but
when when he was making >> I I wish he could have been
a good person, too.
What's that? Do you think I don't wish Do you think I
I built out like a spot in that community where I was going to
make like a lot of money. It was really It was a really really
sweet deal. Do you think I wish he couldn't have been a good
Yeah, but like me >> think Sorry, do you think I don't
wish that? Absolutely I wish that. But but when he was saying
that there was this moment there was this clip that I actually
really really really liked. He was he was saying like okay, now
I don't believe in this, but here's this argument from C.S. Lewis
and I want you to think about it. Now I was like damn. Lauren
must be DMing him about C.S. [laughter] Lewis.
And um you know, like like there's moments like that, man. That
that there's moments
uh uh of like flickers. And and by the way, like um the the binary
the the the binary of goodness and badness
um that that you're you're kind of appealing uh I that's not
how I conceptualize people at all. Oh, sure. I wish he hadn't
done so many like very negative actions that I would have to
like walk away from anybody else for such that like I couldn't
possibly look through it or past it even for massive amounts
of money.
Okay. So while I don't think he's evil, I think there's like
I I think there's legitimate pathology there. Like I do think
um as Supreme said right off the bat, like he probably needs
help. Like he actually probably some kind of help. Like there
is something pathological there that he doesn't have access to
that needs to be resolved for him to live like a fruitful and
happy life going forward. So there's absolutely something like
that going on. Uh difficult to put my like I'm not a psychologist,
so I can't put my finger on exactly where it is.
Right? Okay. Take that back. No, I mean I mean I I would I would
make an argument for
I would I would make an argument for maybe not like a giga conservative
life, but I would I would want him to
consider some conservative stuff, but but that's okay. Yeah,
I like what you said where obviously he's like hanging out with
Impa Chad. Like I I find that particularly funny when you have
to go and sit there and like pretend that her staying alone in
his apartment and traveling with him to America events and he's
like I've never had sex with this person. I don't have anything
with this It's like brother.
That that that that isn't even the isn't even the concerning
part. It's the it's the liability to the people around you. So
that that's the like like I I think I went a little crazy on
that video, but I still think the the thrust of what I said is
100% accurate, which is effectively like what if you are just
now
I'll reiterate kind of the way that I felt about it and feel
about it is like if you're just now kind of surviving your court
case, why are you inviting this kind of chaos? Not not even for
your sake. Whatever. You want to you want to blow up your own
personal life again through self some self-destructive masochistic
urge, whatever. Uh why would you do that to your uh professional
peers? And and I felt like that was like a a huge liability
uh for almost no no payoff that I could think of. Yeah, so that
was basically what I have been saying since January where it's
like very obvious to I I'm sorry, I'm just going to say it again.
It's very obvious to me that this person literally just prioritizes
themselves above everything including the politics. That they
are not not responsible enough to lead a political movement.
That while they have a big audience and they can you know, be
uh transgressive and like funny to that audience and even make
good points sometimes, they are in fact always going to self-destruct.
They're always going to set that movement back. As long as they're
at the head of it, that movement won't be successful.
In my opinion. Okay. Okay. Fair enough. Then um any any saved
rounds Anything else we should cover? >> you would agree
Well, we're going to have to cover this quote from the video
real quick before you go. But you would agree that like that's
that's your criticism. You are If you're not intentionally echoing,
you're unintentionally echoing, which is even better. That you've
looked at it independently, come to the same determination. I
can't understand why you keep doing this when we have like a
movement we're trying to be behind you. We're trying to trust
you and you are risking this movement for nothing.
The Yeah, so the the difference
um I think I think the difference in our approach it's probably
approaches rather than that description of
that Steven
Can we I think we're all we've already been real tonight. I'm
I'm going to be extra real. Um Steven is
with or without me, with or without Erudite, with or without
Dan, with or without Mouton. Uh Steven is a >> What's that?
Going to have a community? Sorry, I'm trying to finish your sentence.
You just go ahead. >> No, no, no, no. I was going to say
he's a digital media empire.
Okay? Yeah. Um a a a six or seven figure income. I know he's
demonetized on YouTube or whatever, but I think he could just
as easily move to uh Kick or
um Rumble or something like that and he could probably build
back a six or seven figure digital media empire near instantaneously.
Now he's going to lose uh because YouTube is such a big thing.
He's going to lose >> Did you think he was going to go
to Rumble and get a positive deal?
No, no, no, no. I'm I'm saying that if he had to start from scratch,
I still think he could start from scratch.
Oh, probably, yeah. I mean he he'll never have to start from
scratch. He's got his website with all of his subscriptions and
the community there, >> Right. Right. Yeah, he he talks
about like how losing YouTube makes him want to retire because
the costs are too much and I'm like dude, just tell people to
go to your website and shill every 30 minutes to an hour and
say, "Hey, in order to keep the content going, I need you to
super chat." And I almost guarantee you he would make more than
any streamer I know, I guess.
So anyways, sure. Um the the so he's the head of a digital media
empire with or without me, with or without Erudite, with or without
Dan, without with or without Mouton, okay? Mhm. And so that digital
media empire can be
uh used for good or it can be used for ill and the truth is that
it's probably going to be used for something, you And so you've
kind of taken the approach of I cannot be a part of this anymore
because my personal morals have been violated so much to the
point that I feel like I'm complicit
in uh said moral violations.
Where I think my approach has been uh fa- faultingly
uh failingly is that uh Steven is a person. He's in a weird
weird industry.
Um where most people
are looking for
uh covert
benefit. They almost don't they don't talk about the benefits
of being his friend because to talk about it is to acknowledge
how awkward it is, right? Um until
he commits some egregious moral failing that they then have to
backstab him over or frontstab him over. And so as a result,
if you just go back for the through the past five or 10 years,
um it it's just this like long it's this conveyor belt of people
backstabbing or frontstabbing him. And so because I was a person
before I was a a streamer or a YouTuber, You understand that
there's like another way of framing that, right? Which is like
Yeah, absolutely. >> continuously [__] up and
people holding him to task in a totally reasonable way. No, people
holding him to task in a totally reasonable way and then him
lying and misrepresenting those people to the point that they
go, "Oh, this guy's actually a total piece of shit." Like you
understand that's what happened with Max, right? That Max had
a total point with the Nick Fuentes thing. Like 100% had a perfect
point and basically got lied about and like crazy made. He went
he eventually ends up on some Reddit thing, which by the way,
is the exact thing Destiny's asking Pisko for, 100%. Hey, why
won't you moderate your community for me? It's really [__]
up that you won't moderate your community at all for me. It's
really [__] up. Right? We can agree that he's 100%
hip Pisko for this. The exact thing that Max came to him for.
Max got crazy made and then Max went and and listened to people
who also said he was abusive and tried to write a report on it.
And by the way, with the actual descriptive analysis the beginning
of that report, quite
Okay, but did you um I I I I think the way that I say because
Steven watched my coverage or my conversation with Pisko about
that exact event. Uh let let's just say I think the way that
I cover it and the way that Queen Man covers it and the way that
you cover it are probably a little
rhetorically different. While still talking about the same flaw.
>> what? Max was like taking over his subreddit? Like Forethought
didn't like >> no, no. Um that that I was saying >> Oh,
go ahead. What what what I said to Pisko was I said is I have
no [__]
with the way that you're running your community because a a person's
community, a person's Reddit, a person's Discord is his castle.
So if he wanted to fill it with snarkers and Jay stalkers and
queefers and kiwi farmers, that's his business as a creator.
And you know, no no man
who no man in who has a digital media >> Yeah, but sorry,
you understand that hold on. outsiders and how they manage their
digital media empire.
Just be clear, there's like a frustration I have with you sometimes
and I I don't know how to I don't know I have to call it out
now cuz it's something you do a lot. We're discussing Destiny's
hypocrisy in
condemning Pisco and being mad at Mr. Girl and you brought up
your position which is totally irrelevant to the conversation
and I don't know why you brought it up right there. Because what
you think is totally irrelevant to judging the hypocrisy of Destiny
and how he handled those two different situations. >> I'm
saying I maybe your audience is too dense to understand this.
I think you're smart enough to understand this. I'm saying I
agree with old Destiny. And the accusation of hypocrisy is accurate
and Steven should stop giving a [__] what's happening
in Pisco's discord. That's exactly what I just said. It's immediately
pertinent.
But who you understand that it would be hypocrisy even if you
agreed with new Destiny, right? Yeah, with yes.
But I but I still >> why I'm saying it's irrelevant to
the conversation. So that was like you did that. But it's not
irrelevant because that effectively gives Pisco and arguably
you rhetorical information to say that Steven's incorrect. That
you do you think wait, where am I going to say that while counterpoints
agrees with me? Is that You could. I still it doesn't have to
do with the hypocrisy. That's all. I it's fine. And by the way,
that's more in like debates and stuff in a general conversation
like this. I understand it's a part of a friendly conversation.
I'm just like it's it could be frustrating to me when I'm like
I'm asking you about this hypocrisy that that's like clearly
dumb, that's clearly insane to to do to someone and like it's
all in the open. It's why I have a hard time dealing with this
community at all because they will actually not that you did
this, but his community will minimize all of his hypocrisies
away and try to explain them away and never analyze them like
directly at all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, maybe I'm um
maybe I'm misunderstanding. I might be getting tired, but I think
me saying
no, I think he is being hypocritical in saying that
Pisco's community is being hostile to him and he should police
it more aggressively
in spite of the fact that he had the opposite arguments with
Max
I agree with old Steven saying you, this is my community. I do
what I want and that's clearly a hypocrisy that Steven can be
criticized for. I feel like that's pertinent, but
It is well, again, it's the hypocrisy, but we don't have to go
through it again. It's fine. Okay. Okay. The well, being a hypocrite
is not the worst crime. The it's it's like Bill Cosby.
>> We play the we play that Norm MacDonald clip here all
the time.
>> The the the Patton Oswalt claim? Yeah, the Patton Patton
Oswalt and Norm MacDonald and Jerry Seinfeld. He said the worst
[laughter] thing about Bill Cosby is the hypocrisy.
All right, anyway, sorry, sorry, sorry.
No problem. Right, right. >> Yeah, we play that all the
time.
Um yeah, yeah, so so hold on, hold on, hold on. There were there
was a deeper point here though, which is effectively
the approach that I'm taking is I'm assuming that there has been
a conveyor belt of bad relationships that Steven has had and
regardless of whether or not we're friends in perpetuity, I just
want to be transparent.
I I just want to be transparent and I want to be
friendly and I want to be a friend. Sometimes he makes that difficult
and I and I've told him that. But I want to be a friend as much
as I can because I'm hoping that people who have grace and maybe
a little bit of mercy and forgiveness can kind of mellow him
over time. He's not going to be 19 forever even if he he's making
a hard run of it. Uh-huh. Like like if I if I suffered the consequences
that Steven had suffered over the past year,
I wouldn't engage in any of this behavior ever again, I suppose.
So we we need to see if Steven learns his lesson. Yeah, I'm sure
this time he'll learn it for sure.
For sure. Okay, sorry, you were saying you wanted to finish the
clip before we wrap?
Um well, I don't really care about the clip. It's just like you're
saying that my positions on this aren't what they were. Like
I literally for maybe after 2 weeks not even 2 weeks. I think
I read the statutes. I went through stuff and I'm like, oh, actually
it might be a lot harder to do this. So from
with some of the intense stuff, you could do the constructive
thing. But from that point forward, I'm pretty much always on
the the perspective of I think Destiny's going to I think Destiny's
like advantaged. It's just going to come down to discovery. Like
I don't know which way this is going to go. It's just going to
come down to discovery. What do they find in discovery, right?
That's been my opinion the whole time. So like the idea that
I'm saying it's all over for him. If you want to say that Riles'
thumbnails say that, then maybe, but like again, it's the actual
content. If you listen to the things I say, that has not been
my position for a very, very, very long time. If it ever was,
I still think I was pretty hesitant to say that like, oh, he's
definitely going down. Except I did think probably in terms of
the what do you call it? Probably in terms of the
of what would we call it? The criminal charges, I do think he'll
be charged criminally. But that that's my impression. That was
my impression. I would have made a bet on it. You used to or
you still do?
Um I mean, it would be more difficult to make that bet now, but
I I still probably would make that bet. So I bet somebody I think
five dollars. Just to make sure that I heard you correctly. You're
saying you still think he will get hit with a criminal charge
Um I mean, I don't know.
I don't know. I I probably if I if you wanted to bet like 50/50
on that, I would probably still bet you, but I don't know if
that's like
like that's not based on private information. That's based on
what I knew from before from like public information from before,
>> I think I should say this. I think it's important. So
with with Sherry, bear in mind I I do not know all of the details,
okay? I'm operating off of public information as well and I know
this, you know, might be a little bit awkward, but I'm going
to say it. Um with Sherry, let's say that the wiretapping law
was what was violated by Steven allegedly doing an audio recording
of a consensual sexual encounter without the consent of the other
party, okay? There is a statute that could cover that and I think
it's like Florida's wiretapping law and I think it's like a misdemeanor
of a first degree which is the more serious misdemeanor. Um or
it could be a felony of a third degree which is the less serious
felony, but I forget which one it is. Um in order for that to
be criminally prosecuted, effectively what would need need to
happen in my opinion is Sherry who I do not know her personal
information would need to file the local police report in whatever
jurisdiction she's currently in. She would need to take the sworn
written affidavit, bring it down to a state attorney in the state
of Florida, find a state attorney who was willing to prosecute
Steven based off of this alleged crime and the
Just based off publicly available information, I can already
say that you are incorrect.
You can say that I'm descriptively correct or incorrect.
Incorrect. Okay, well, maybe you could tell me off of um maybe
[snorts] you could tell me without too much detail >> I
would just say you can look up what's public. I'm I'm probably
not going to talk about it. But I don't know Sherry's personal
information. So you're saying like I could look up what's public
what what am I going to do? Am I going
what I I guess this is how I would do >> It's fine. That
yeah. If if you need me to because I can't explain anything here.
I'm not going to talk about it. >> it's fine. I don't want
to put you in a bad position.
Oh, is Destiny in chat? Destiny's in chat apparently. Um okay.
The but I was going to say >> account none of you guys
can even stay even remotely true about anything.
Is that like a Nick Shirley reference? Are you true? I am true.
Yes, I am sure I am true. I think that's a Nick Shirley reference
right there.
But the but I would want to see
a state attorney effectively pick up the case and then
take it from there. But but that's where if we're if we're a
year on and we don't have any movement, then I would presume
that it would be dead.
So you you could say that you think differently or there's public
evidence to the contrary
and I actually thought of how I could research that. So I might
research that later on, but for me um
I'm not I'm not holding my breath. It's
but I'm not holding my breath. >> would say this is one
of those cases where you like really haven't looked into it and
like there's there's publicly available information you could
see that would probably convince you, but it's you're just not
going to do it.
No, I mean, I'll tell you I'll tell you what I'm going to do
because this is what I would do. >> it come down to what
actually happens, right? No, I don't Destiny's saying I'm making
things up. I wonder what I've claimed that he feels like I'm
making things up with. Okay, but I'm going to say this because
once again, the truth is the truth. I'm going to go like I will
probably it's not going to be a huge priority, but I'll probably
do it. I will probably go to the district of Miami
clerk of courts. I'm going to look up Steven's name as a defendant
and I'm going to see if there's any ongoing cases and I I think
that's
that's where my next step is.
Because that that that would be
the the next step to finding the alleged public information about
the court case.
You could do whatever you want. I again,
I probably shouldn't even be talking about it at all.
Are are you going to bring Steven in or are you going to leave
him out there?
I'm not bringing him in. I've already said I'm not talking to
him directly. He can ask questions or he can point out where
I've lied about something if he wants. Okay.
Okay. Well, yeah, what else
I guess what what else did we want to cover tonight?
You're not banned from my Discord? That's incredible. I don't
know how he's not banned. I think he just Yeah, just I would
just wonder like what I would just wonder what points that I've
made that he thinks are lies. Yeah, I don't know. May- maybe
he'll answer in chat. I just I just told him that uh you said
no to him coming in. The I He could just say like what I lied
about.
Well, and let me pull myself up on screen and you on screen.
So,
I think in reference to this clip though, cuz I think we were
trying to put a nice little bow on it. In reference to the bow,
you, like I said, most of the things that I had that were direct
quotes were Kelly Jean Queenman, Lav,
Sunday, people who ostensibly were quote unquote on your team,
but I didn't have direct quotes for you besides the infinite
rape machine. You've already said that you were descriptive,
however, you agree with this element of it. And then what I would
say is I pointed out the irony that I felt like you and Queenman
were super hot last year, but you weren't covered in as much,
but you also explained that within our conversation
um that effectively the the juice is not worth the squeeze.
And so, you know, I mean, I think that's like a rational >> he's
going to be in chat most nights, it might be worth the squeeze.
Well, that's what [laughter] I Dude, that's what I'm But the
This is kind of my point, man. It's like you you got Steven in
the waiting room. You could drag him in. You could probably boost
viewership by 30%. You would obviously increase super chats.
You guys could scream at each other, sperg at each other, call
you call each other vile >> I should pull the guy who's
doxxed multiple people in my community into my chat? Into my
onto my >> Yeah, it's probably fire content.
I don't I Hold on. I don't want content like that. I don't want
him to go in like say somebody's name in my stream again. I signed
up for that once. And also, not only that, I watched him debate
with Pisco without a moderator there, and I watched how much
he lied about Pisco. Lied about everything Pisco was saying,
right? Repeatedly, over and over and over again. Just lied, talked
over the guy, wouldn't let anything happen, right?
And I have no interest >> I think I think in that conversation
I don't know what the lie is. I felt like he was saying that
he felt like Pisco was overly friendly with a bunch of his detractors.
No, it was when Pis- Pisco was actually trying to extract concessions
on Destiny's lies. That was when he would just talk over him
and
Repeatedly. Um may- maybe >> there's any point having a
discussion with Destiny. He is a bad faith actor who will never
have an honest conversation, but if he wants to go ahead and
say anything I lied about from the chat, I'll pull one up. Hold
on, he said something. He actually made a claim that I said he
had five cases against him. I did not. I said you have at least
with five people shared the material non-consensually. That's
true.
Where's the lie there? Each one of those people have said that
already.
Melina, Pixie, uh hold on. Abby, Melina, Pixie, I can I can do
this. Stasia and Cherry.
Where's the Where's I Where's the lie? That's like all all publicly
on the record. Okay.
I I I guess I'm I would I'm just being real. I would love to
be here for you guys to fight, but if you're not interested in
the fight, I'm not going to try to force you into it. Um so,
is there is there something else we should cover before uh we
wrap? Is there something we should cover? Oh, I was just saying
that I don't think any of the positions that you ascribed to
me are ones I had or that I actually have. >> Okay. And
and I I think that you said that after the first 2 weeks you
didn't have them. I agree that most of the the things that I
objected to were other people who were quote unquote in your
orbit. And then the one thing
that you told me that you actually believe in and you said you
still believe, which is effectively an element of the infinite
rape machine. Um and then also you told me that the juice isn't
worth the squeeze. So, I said
it's weird that Queenman and Jay Stalk aren't capitalizing on
Destiny's court case, and you told me why you're not capitalizing
on the court case. So, I mean, I think that's
that resolves my criticism.
Yeah, I also I just said that I was getting like way more viewers
off of the stuff I was covering, right? And that I would cover
the transcripts. I'm sorry, I it went low volume. What was that?
Oh, I said I would cover the transcript, that I just wasn't covering
it yesterday cuz there was breaking news.
Okay. Yeah. All right, cool. Anything else before we wrap?
Uh no, I don't think so. So, again, I just pointed out that Destiny
lied. If Destiny wants to show Sorry, I'm going to go ahead,
but thanks for coming on.
Yeah, buddy. I'm totally fine with doing the the Asmongold Hasan
thing though with him, so we can keep doing that in a Thank you
for coming on. Yeah, yeah. Have a good night. Yeah, you too.
See you.